Tell me when it's up for folks who just tuned in on Ustream.
We just started talking about,
uh,
Sam Harris,
the big,
big fat Islamophobe.
What does that man,
is that it,
because they're brown,
is that because people are trying to be like super progressive?
Is that what,
whoops.
Yeah.
Um,
it's a,
it's a very dangerous irony and double standard.
It's really,
it's one of the most disturbing phenomenon,
I think,
uh,
to just to be found on the landscape.
Now.
It's a poor folks tuning in on Ustream just to keep you up to date.
Um,
we were talking about how you can make fun of Christianity with no problems
whatsoever.
I make fun of Mormonism.
Nobody cares.
But if you make fun of Islam,
progressive people will call you Islamophobic.
Yeah.
It's a combination of very understandable fears of racism and xenophobia.
So we have this,
we're obviously trailing a legacy that we should be mortified by this theater,
a legacy of slavery and colonialism and,
um,
and all of that is something we should,
we should have a critical distance from and not wanting to recapitulate in any
form.
And so it,
it's,
it's important to be mindful of that obviously,
but there's this,
this,
um,
combination of,
of white guilt and political correctness and just sheer Stockholm syndrome and
some people that it has made it impossible to criticize Islam without being
branded a racist and Islam traditional.
Because if you're not going to buy traditional than conservative,
if you're not going to buy conservative than extremists,
there's some version of Islam that is the most odious ideology operative.
Now.
It is just,
it is a leading directly to the immiseration and millions of people.
And the moment you try to,
uh,
really draw a straight line and,
and myriad straight lines exist between that phenomenon and the actual doctrine
of Islam.
The actual idea said,
handed down from Muhammad,
you're accused of,
of bigotry and your leader put right next to Michelle Bachmann and any,
anyone else on the,
on the right who obviously you can't,
uh,
you can't ally within any sense.
Um,
so it's,
it's,
it's very,
um,
it's very troubling because,
because you have a,
those whole websites and magazines like salon and,
and um,
alternate and even the nation that just reflectively demonize anyone who has
said anything about Islam,
the religion that's negative and that's a,
it's a double standard.
We're going to have to overcome.
Salon goes hard,
they go hard with progressive silliness.
I mean they got mad at Patton Oswald for making a joke about someone making a
joke about Chinese accents like that.
It was so stupid.
It made them look so petty,
pedantic and silly.
It's just like,
what are you guys doing?
Like there's a lot of like real issues going on in the world.
There's a lot of real things to think about in this day and age.
Yeah.
I wrote a blog post about Malala Yousafzai the uh,
the 16 year old girl who was at 15 shot by the Taliban and was up for the Nobel
prize,
which she didn't win.
Uh,
but should have.
And My,
My blog post was totally praiseworthy of her.
I said,
she is the best thing to come out of the Muslim world.
And a thousand years she should've won the Nobel prize.
She's elegant,
eloquent and brave.
And um,
and the headline and Salon was Sam Harris,
slurs Malala.
And My slur was not,
uh,
basically accepting her view of Islam as the canonical Islam cause she's not an
atheist and I,
and,
and they,
they thought I was sort of Co coopting her as an atheist,
which obviously wasn't doing.
So it's just,
it's incredibly frustrating because so many smart people or otherwise smart
people are taken in by this because people really want to believe that all
religions are the same and that people everywhere the same and want the same
things.
And if we just got our act together on the world stage,
if we just,
if we just ceased to exploit people and we cease to be selfish and we just,
and when we pulled back all the drones,
everyone would behave the same way.
We would have rational actors everywhere.
And there's just no evidence for that.
And,
and there's,
there's just as much evidence as you could possibly want to find for the
antithesis,
which is there are some people who are in a death cult who are certain of
paradise and very eager to get there.
Uh,
and they're not,
there's no talking to them.
And then there's a,
there's a,
a much vaster number of,
of people around them who support them,
who are not jihadists,
but who are basically aligned with them in terms of the worldview.
So,
um,
you know,
we have to win a war of ideas and we have to win a war and we have to be honest
about it.
Yeah.
We,
we certainly do.
And there's this weird thing going on right now in Saudi Arabia where women are
protesting,
uh,
the,
right to drive.
They're all driving.
And this is a big issue and it's crazy that in 2013 and that is directly related
to religion.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's incredibly edgy and risky to do.
It's just amazing to get,
if you're a woman,
to get behind the wheel of a car in Saudi Arabia is a,
um,
a life disorienting risk,
you know,
to make that kind of social protest.
Um,
so if at best they're behind us by whatever,
50 years,
75 years in certain social,
um,
uh,
epiphany's,
you know,
so,
so if you roll back the clock in the U S and look at racism,
we don't really have the same analogous religious
brainwashing,
but,
but if you look at racism in the u s and what was going on in the,
in the teens and twenties and thirties,
it's just unthinkable.
Now,
let me just lynchings and,
and,
uh,
newspaper editorials that were starkly racism and they're there in newspaper
editorials,
not op eds,
but actually the editorial of,
of the New York Times and La Times,
uh,
in 1910,
1915 that
read exactly like a KKK pamphlet behind just,
just mind boggling.
So at,
at the very least,
we have societies that have to catch up in their attitudes towards women and
homosexuals and pluralism and atheism.
And,
uh,
we have to facilitate that process by not caving in when free speech issues come
up.
So when,
when someone draws a cartoon and the Prophet Muhammad and people start burning
embassies,
the move on our side can't be to apologize for cartooning and,
and to,
and to become self critical and masochistic about,
you know,
why is it that we had these cartoonists that did this terrible thing and,
and uh,
and that's,
and that's essentially what we did.
And we pulled all the no magazine with the exception of one a free inquiry in
the u s publish those cartoons.
There were totally benign cartoons.
You probably saw them that are available online.
But,
um,
we,
we practiced self censorship to a degree that is just,
just astonishing and really just harmful to,
to,
to this,
um,
this conflict that both the hot and cold conflict that we're having,
it's caricature.
It's a caricature of a overblown reaction that you get from someone that maybe
was put in a situation where they will want to always use this as an excuse for
why things are like,
it's racism.
This is racism,
or you just hate women.
Like there's a bunch of these like,
oh,
you're Islamophobic.
It's like boom.
They throw that on you,
this wet blanket.
And that.
It's a weird thing because you call it a cult.
And I agree with you,
but that's a very controversial thing to say.
If you say that people get very upset with you,
but the reality is somebody is in a cult.
Okay,
if you've got 20 different whatever,
how many different religions that are practice worldwide?
I don't know how many,
how many other,
well,
the probably hundreds,
but they're just,
there's a big handful of main ones we care about.
But the main ones who care about,
okay,
let's just say there's only four.
Someone's in a cult.
Someone's lying some day,
have four different stories.
So what's going on?
Who's telling the truth?
Someone's in a call and no one's willing to admit that this pie,
of course,
everyone believes the other people are in a cult.
But just the cognitive dissonance allow,
uh,
involved in picking some ancient ideology and thinking at some point in time,
somebody actually had a conversation with the divine,
wrote it down verbatim and it's perfect.
And it's never been touched by the hand of man or distorted.
It's,
it's weird that you get that from something like salon and that's essentially
what they're doing.
But calling you Islamophobia.
Yeah.
They're endorsing this idea that this wacky cult that makes you kill people,
they draw a picture of their guy.
Women aren't allowed to drive cars,
you suicide bombing.
And in this day and age,
it's like very,
very common and religious based.
Sure.
That's the most extreme faction of that religion.
And there's many people that are moderate Muslims who despise that as much as we
do.
But still it's,
it's an ideology and ideologies are real problems.
Yeah.
Well,
the,
the dispute is that,
uh,
the link that I'm drawing and that many other people draw between that behavior
and the religion is being challenged.
So,
so the people who had brand me as in Islam as a Llama,
Islamophobia would say that this behavior has nothing to do with Islam in
principle is that one,
you have extremists in every religion and they all misbehave or bad people will
do bad things anyway.
And,
and religion has always a pretext.
Uh,
and that is just not true.
The scary phenomenon.
Um,
uh,
I think the most scary phenomenon really to be witnessed anywhere is that you
can have psychologically healthy,
rational,
otherwise competent and capable and charismatic people who have other
opportunities in life.
You know,
the,
the good,
the quarterback of the football team can become a jihadist given the right
ideas,
uh,
and it,
and if you just admit to yourself that certain people actually believe in
paradise and believe that there's a specific way to get there that entails
violent,
defensive of the faith,
then it becomes totally rational to behave this way.
Then you and I would be flying planes into buildings if we actually believe
this.
It doesn't matter what other opportunities you have in life.
And the thing that most secular liberals can't get their minds around is that
people actually believe in paradise.
People actually believe that,
that that is certain book was dictated by the creator of the universe.
And it has provided a blueprint,
uh,
and a moral framework,
um,
that many,
many people,
millions of people believe it's perfect and unchallengeable for all time.
And then once you admit,
once you admit that,
you just have to look at the blueprint and this,
this particular blueprint,
it says a lot about a holy war,
uh,
and fighting the infidel and subjugating the infidel and killing apostates.
So,
you know,
if you,
if you convert to Islam now on this show,
and then by the end of the show is a,
a,
you know,
I thought better of it.
I don't feel like being a Muslim anymore.
I'm unconverted.
That is a crime punishable by death.
Uh,
and that's just,
that's not extremist Islam.
That's not,
I was in a training camp in Afghanistan with 10,000 other lunatics,
Islam,
that is plain vanilla Islam.
Uh,
now you can sorta dicker around the edges of that dogma by saying,
you're dead to me or no,
you can't go that far,
unfortunately dead,
but you're dead to me.
You can say,
well,
the person has to speak out against the faith or repeatedly,
but you know,
he has to be an obnoxious apostate.
But um,
you,
what you don't get are millions and millions of Muslims who belonged to some
bonafide tradition of Islam who say,
oh no,
oh,
apostasy is fine.
You should,
you should be free to change your mind about the faith.
And we don't care if you were once a Muslim and now you've become a Hindu or you
were once a Muslim and now you become a Christian or an atheist,
that is,
that is fine with,
if,
if that existed,
well then you could just point to that brand of Islam and say,
well,
I go over there guys.
That's the,
that's the Islam.
We should be encouraging.
But we have to,
and clearly we have to figure out some way to massage the faith into conformity
with that kind of pluralism and secularism.
But it's just not there.
And for,
for magazines like salon to pretend that that I'm killing apostates has no
connection to the real religion of Islam is just a just pure delusion and it's a
dangerous one.
It's also dangerous just to have a very strict ideology to have a thing that not
just you're supposed to do because the culture wants you to do it,
but because God wants you to.
That's weird.
It's,
it's,
it's dumb.
It's weird.
It's,
it's insane.
If you think that in 2013 with the kind of access to information we have,
that we really believe that someone actually wrote this stuff down from the
divine.
It's craziness.
It's a crit with Christianity,
whether it's Mormon is a,
Mormonism is hilarious and Mormonism and Scientology are my two favorites
because we know the guy who made them,
you know,
those are,
and we know they were the Kahneman book,
not just con man,
way too much about them.
Yeah,
I'm an L.
Ron Hubbard was a fucking science fiction author.
He me to science fiction religion.
I mean,
it's really beautiful in a way.
It's a hilariously beautiful,
and someone like me who appreciates the folly of life,
I can appreciate that in a big way.
I'm,
it's just,
it's,
it's like endless comedy.
It's just so stupid.
Yeah.
What is it though?
Why do we need something?
But why does everybody need something?
But the,
the,
it's crucial that you acknowledge the difference between the various ideologies
on offer because just how,
just believing,
believing that your worldview has come from God is not necessarily a deal
breaker in terms of living in a global civil society.
If that worldview prescribes lots of benign things.
I mean,
so if you think God told you to be a vegetarian and never harm anyone and learn
everything you can about science and mathematics and economics and become a,
a really energetic contributor to civil society,
if that's your religion,
well then you're never going to show up on anyone's radar is a dangerous person.
Um,
uh,
it's just the,
the main religions on offered don't have that kind of,
those kinds of ideas.
Uh,
and um,
you know,
they have first century and,
uh,
Iron Age,
platitudes and strictures that,
that have now been canonized in these books.
And there's just,
there's no way to rewrite the books.
He can't edit the book.
So who people effectively edit the books by ignoring the most barbarous stuff in
there.
But there's no way to say we're going to,
we as Muslims where as Christians are going to craft a new scripture that's in
line with all that we've come to learn about the universe,
uh,
and follow that as though it were the word of God because the,
they would know they were making it up and,
and that's um,
that's not satisfying.
Christians are funny because they ignore things conveniently.
Like I've met so many Christians that have Christian Bible quote tattoos.
Like,
did you read that thing?
You're not supposed to do that right to write on yourself.
Now he's supposed to use a magic marker and here you are getting a tattoo of a
bible quote that's like,
you know,
God's like Jesus Christ did you pay attention to?
I said,
well,
it's a long book.
Unfortunately,
the Quran is not as long a book.
You can read the Quran in a weekend.
It's a much shorter book.
You read the Bible cover to cover,
it takes you a month and a half,
but you read the Koran a,
it's a much more unified document and there's not,
you can't cherry pick,
you can cherry pick out a little bit,
but you can't cherry pick it in quite the same way.
You can't just take Jesus and half his moods the way you can as a Christian and
say,
well,
this is all about turning the other cheek.
And I've got,
I don't care about hell and I don't care about
any of these culture war issues.
Um,
you just can't.
You really can't do that with Islam.
And that's why this fusion of,
of the religion and the politics is so difficult to,
to break because it's,
it's explicit and there's just no,
there's no render unto Caesar those things that are Caesar's in the Koran as
there isn't in the Bible.
So my favorite religion is Mormons.
They're the nicest people.
They're so sweet.
Yeah.
Like every time I've had a Mormon neighbor or you know,
meet Mormons,
they're the nicest people.
They're almost like child life in their belief,
like childlike in their approach to religion.
Like my wife has a friend who's a Mormon.
I went up to dinner with her and her husband and uh,
somewhere along the line the subject of higher power came up.
She was grilling me like,
do you believe in a higher power?
And you know,
basically I said,
well,
I don't not believe.
I don't know.
I mean,
who the fuck knows?
She's like,
you don't know if you don't know,
how do you sleep at night for her?
Like someone had to tell her so she could talk herself in the bed like a little
kid,
like my five year old,
like,
sweetie,
God's Wachovia and everything's gonna be okay.
Okay,
cool.
Like now I can go to sleep.
For her,
it was very challenged.
Fucking 40 year old woman.
Like she had this child like narrow tunnel of thinking that she prescribed to
ex.
Mormons are awesome because there,
there's,
there's no group of people that are more energetic in their atheism.
And I've met them and an ex Mormons because they,
they're coming out of this thing that is just so obviously made up.
I mean,
he's like,
you got Joseph Smith as a dowser and a con man and um,
and 14,
and just,
and just getting it on with everyone's wife and just making up a principal's,
you know,
he's gay.
He gets new revelations to appease his jealous wife and he goes into the closet
and God's,
and God tells him that he's got to have more hot girls.
So it's just,
and it's just so that it's just there in the,
in the flood lights of history to be inspected.
And so once they,
once they get out of it and they see just the,
they're trailing all this nonsense,
um,
they're very,
they're very fun to talk to.
What is it about people
that we need or some people need that they need,
that they need an ideology.
They need a framework and the scaffolding to live their life on.
They can't just free ball it.
They can't just go,
who knows?
Let's just figure out what we already know and apply that to wonder.
They can't do that.
They need an answer.
Well,
uh,
I wouldn't be the first to observe the death has something to do with it.
Is this anxiety about what it all means in light of the fact that at all
apparently ends,
um,
is really a,
a defense against grief.
You know,
the,
these beliefs,
a belief in paradise,
it's really the only thing you can tell yourself or tell another person or tell
your child in the presence of death that makes death fundamentally,
uh,
unproblematic I mean,
so,
so you're,
you're the closest person to you in your life has died or your child has died.
And so what,
what are you going to say to yourself or to the people around you?
Or what can they say to you that is just,
not only,
not only takes the sting out slightly,
but it's just perfectly consoling if you could believe it.
It's this proposition that you're,
you're going to meet again in some perfect place,
uh,
and you're going to spend eternity there and be perfectly happy.
And all you have to do is believe the right things in the meantime,
uh,
and not screw up too badly as a homosexual or it was whatever else is on the
checklist of don'ts.
Um,
and you will get there and you'll be reunited with everyone you care about.
And that,
and that is,
there is no secular or atheist or rational alternative to that.
And I mean that's,
that's a bullet I think we just have to bite.
Is there.
So there's not,
you know,
it at the graveside of a child.
The atheist doesn't have something to say that says this is not a problem.
You know,
this is,
your tiers are wasted,
uh,
and Christians and Muslims and Mormons and basically everyone who posits a
heaven that you're,
that is assured based on the right beliefs.
They do have something to say that,
that the,
the crowd buys into.
And there's no question that it relieves that suffering.
Now,
I think it's,
I think,
I think it comes with a,
uh,
a host of other problems that,
that,
um,
that even,
that trade off is not worth it.
I mean,
if,
even if we grant that's a certain kind of suffering is,
is,
uh,
relieved there.
There's other kinds of suffering that spring up and,
but we,
people are not learning how to grieve.
They're not learning how to teach their children degree.
If they're not,
they're not learning intellectual honesty.
They're not,
um,
uh,
and they're myered in a way of thinking that is constant,
is co causing them constantly to collide with reality in,
in unfortunate ways that they,
they,
they actually don't get what they want in life because they're believing things
that,
that just don't line up with how the world works.
And so you,
I think it's,
it is,
if you,
if you look closely,
you can see that even that,
uh,
you know,
the best thing,
I mean,
the baby and the bathwater of,
of faith is,
um,
it's still dysfunctional.
The Mormon friend,
she applied for a real estate license and didn't get it.
She failed a test and she was upset.
She was like,
I'm a good person.
Why didn't I get it?
I'm doing all the right things and I'm a good person.
That's what she kept saying.
It's like being around a crazy person.
Yeah.
She just believes that if you do God's word,
good things going to happen to you.
I'm a good person.
Why didn't I get this right?
While not looking at the fact that he's rich as fuck lives in a great house,
has healthy kids.
Like there's all this wonderful stuff going on your life.
Like maybe just didn't apply herself enough to this whole real estate thing.
So it's not going to do with God failing you.
All right.
Do you think that religion is something that's allowing human beings to make
this jump from animals to enlightened,
connected beings?
It seems to me that with,
uh,
the connection that we're enjoying through technology,
through the Internet and through the,
the access of information,
it seems to me that we're,
we're slowly but surely dissolving all the boundaries between people and
information and we're going to have much more truth about life and death.
And the the very origins of the universe in a hundred years or a thousand years
then we had a hundred years ago or a thousand years ago.
And I always wonder if like religion is something that's allowed us to keep our
shit together just long enough for some really fucking smart dudes to figure out
the internet,
keep our shit together,
just like keep together morally give,
give these fucking crazy apes some sort of an excuse or a reason to live and you
know,
so they don't just go marauding and jump off clips out of despair and give them
something that allows them to continue the work and that work being society
ultimately moving towards some sort of technological innovation.
Zero point,
you know,
like everything we do,
whether it's cell phones or laptops or cars,
every year it's better.
No one ever goes,
we're good.
This is this cell phone.
I have this galaxy note.
No one's ever going to look at this and go,
this thing's perfect.
Okay,
we're done.
We don't ever have to make another cell phone again.
We're going to continue to move forward faster speeds,
more connections,
more apps,
more things that they can do,
holograms,
time,
travel,
whatever the fuck it's going to be,
it's,
we're never going to stop.
And it almost sometimes I wonder if,
what,
what religion has,
it's just like some sort of a scaffolding that lets us build society on.
Yeah,
I actually don't view it that way.
I think it's there,
there are people who think that religion paid every evolutionary dividends
because it allowed large groups of people,
large groups of,
of kind of dimly related people,
you know,
not just just family,
but larger tribes to cohere in a way that they couldn't otherwise.
So it's a,
the way to get a bunch of strangers to cohere is to put a big idol in the corner
and say,
you know,
anyone who trespasses,
the God is going to be killed.
Uh,
and we're going to,
we're going to commit a sacrifice of a few kids,
uh,
you know,
every month or so.
Um,
and keep everyone in line.
And we're going to,
and outsiders who come into our world who don't understand are taboos.
And our,
and our precepts are going to be easily recognizable as outsiders.
And so there's a long list of things that people think religion may have given,
uh,
our ancestors.
That may be true.
I happen to think that that religion,
most of what explains religion is just more fundamental cognitive and emotional
mechanisms that have nothing in principle to do with religion and which have
also given us science and reason and everything else that,
that we,
that is recognizable as,
as human cognition.
So,
uh,
I mean,
I think the,
the most rudimentary piece here is belief formation.
You and I and every other human being who is neurologically intact has learned
that comes into this world equipped to represent reality in language and to
trade in those representations and to,
and to give them credence to one or another degree.
So you tell me where this the studio is.
I believe you.
I,
it's just language,
right?
And,
and the,
the language got me here.
My belief in the language got me here.
Um,
if I thought that I had transcribed the address wrong,
um,
that belief would have caused me to call you and getting to make sure I got the
eyes.
So I mean this is all just,
these are all just ones and Zeros in our,
in our computer at the moment.
But,
um,
uh,
virtually the totality of our worldview is linguistically mediated in this way.
Um,
uh,
everything is not a matter of direct sensory perception in each moment.
So a religion is just part of that is part of,
it's the set of beliefs people form for which they have very loose evidentiary
criteria and which govern,
uh,
all these no go areas for science.
Uh,
you know,
what happens after death,
what is the meaning of life?
What is,
you know,
what's,
um,
uh,
what's the most important thing,
to live for a and now I think,
I think actually reason Ken capture all of those conversations as well.
And it is in the process of doing it.
But,
uh,
it really is just a matter of believing certain propositions and the rules by
which we,
we vet those beliefs when we are in conversation with one another.
And the problem with faith is that it really operates as the permission.
People give one another to believe things strongly without evidence.
And we don't give that permission in any other area of our lives.
We don't give that permission in science.
We don't give it an in politics a insofar as we're,
we're,
we're practicing politics that anyone can tolerate.
Um,
and it a,
um,
that permission,
that the,
the taboo around criticizing that faith,
um,
is something we've,
we're
hopefully getting over.
We're going to have to get over it because it is the reason why people oppose
gay marriage.
It is the reason why people want laws that make a blast for me,
a criminal offense.
Um,
and so that's,
um,
uh,
it's just a,
in so far as you actually believe something,
it can't help but show up in the public sphere.
And I believe people think beliefs are private.
They're not,
they're only private if there's nothing in your life or in the environment that
is calling them out.
But the moment that they are relevant to your behavior,
they can't help but inform your behavior insofar as you actually believe them.
And that's a,
it's just,
Eh,
I mean,
this is an example I gave and,
um,
and one of my books by as like a,
a belief,
a true belief in the efficacy of prayer is dangerous.
If you,
insofar as you really believe it,
you are going to be tempted to rely on prayer.
You're going to be tempted to rely on prayer for your children.
You've got these people that won't take their children to doctors because they
think prayer is going to work.
I mean,
imagine if you had a pilot who's,
who's trying to land the plane with prayer.
Uh,
it,
it's,
it's clear that,
I mean,
it's,
it's a ridiculous example because we think no one would ever do that.
But in some sense,
people do that in situations where the stakes are just as high.
And certainly everyone who's waging jihad thinks that their belief in paradise
is,
um,
is true.
And it's the,
it's the credence they give to that,
that real just pure language in the mind that is,
um,
is so dangerous.
Did religion,
did religion ever play,
uh,
an important function in society?
Did it ever allow people to get past the barbarian ways and,
and,
uh,
apply some sort of moral and ethical rules to,
to society?
Did it ever have any function or any positive benefit that maybe wouldn't have
come about if people were just a,
a bunch of savage tribal people?
Well,
yeah,
you can,
you can say that it did.
But see,
I look at it from the other side.
So,
so for instance,
when you say that,
that when you look at all the good things Christians have done under the ages of
Christianity,
uh,
occasionally you can,
you can point to something in the doctrine of Christianity that seems to be the
operative variables so that the AUC,
if that doctrine we're different behavior would be different.
But for the most part,
what you see is just people being,
people trying to get what they want out of life.
They're building bridges and they're learning about disease and they're,
they're,
they're trying to,
to,
uh,
develop a scientific principles.
Uh,
and it just so happens they're all Christians doing this.
And,
and w Christianity doesn't really get credit for the birth of science.
It shouldn't get credit for the birth of,
it shouldn't get credit for all the bridges we built or,
or,
uh,
the roads we paved.
Um,
it's just,
there was no one else to do the job in,
in Europe.
You know,
this,
this was the,
everyone was a Christian.
Everyone came into this world and was indoctrinated into a worldview that they
got on mother's knee.
And there was nowhere,
there was,
there was no other worldview on offer.
So,
um,
I mean,
it's,
it's just as true to say that everyone,
virtually everyone who ever fought a war or,
or saved a life or built a bridge did it in complete ignorance of Darwinian
evolution.
Right?
That doesn't,
that doesn't mean that ignorance of Darwinian evolution was the crucial variable
there,
or as a good thing,
or it's something we should want to promote or that was something we should,
we should,
we should safeguard.
Uh,
it's just so happens that that prior to 1859,
this notion of evolution was not,
uh,
it was not an idea that had,
had,
had appeared in anyone's head.
And so,
uh,
there was no alternative but to not know anything about evolution.
And now we could have gotten,
if you,
you could draw a line from and the ancient Greece,
uh,
and,
give us a civilization with a very rich dialogue about ethics and about,
uh,
social norms that would not have needed to invoke the war God of Abraham.
Let me say like Plato,
uh,
could have given us the basis to think rationally about the good life and,
you know,
Plato and everyone like emanation,
Greece.
Um,
and that,
that is a,
that is a stream of ideas that is unencumbered by,
uh,
this notion of,
of,
you know,
maybe,
maybe there's an invisible monster out in the desert who wants a human sacrifice
from time to time and maybe had a son who,
uh,
who died for our sins.
Uh,
so it's,
it's a,
um,
so I know,
I don't think it's actually,
even if religion has seemed to do it in certain circumstances,
I don't think it was actually a necessary piece.
I think we are so deeply wired as social creatures to care about ethics that
ethics was going to show up anyway.
So Christian ethics was not an editing,
just Christian and Jewish and Muslim ethics.
We're not,
not a necessary a scaffold for us,
but there's also examples of dehumanization of the other really common examples,
the way societies are allowed to look at their enemy as not being human and
commit horrible atrocities because of that.
There's a,
a ton of examples of that.
Um,
well that,
that's our default.
Yes.
Our default is the guys over in the next valley.
We don't know them.
I mean it's a chimps have that,
right.
So you,
so chimps will band together in,
in war park parties and kill other chimps who are,
who are not part of their tribe.
Um,
if they happened out number them.
And that is a behavior that clearly we tribalistic xenophobic violence is,
is,
is clearly something we are good at and,
and do reflexively in a,
um,
a state of nature.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean that's,
that's where we start.
So we overcome that by extending the,
the circle of our morality and extending our,
our relationships with our economic relationships,
our cultural relationships are,
are,
are peaceful collaboration with strangers.
I mean,
that's what,
that's what civilization is.
Civilization is a machine to get us to peacefully collaborate with strangers.
And that's,
and the friend that,
you know,
the frontal cortex of every human brain is a machine that allows for that
collaboration.
And it's if you damage that in a,
in an individual,
you get a,
uh,
I mean there's many different pathologies there,
but one is,
is psychopathy may wouldn't say that we,
if you have the right damage to your brain,
you are someone who sees no basis for collaboration.
You don't feel empathy for other people.
Uh,
you either don't care that you make them suffer or you,
you actually take sadistic pleasure in making them suffer.
And uh,
you,
uh,
this,
the,
the very basis for trust breaks down in relation to such a person and they're,
what I would argue is that there are actually cultures that are,
for all intents and purposes,
psychopathic.
There is in which you can put perfectly normal individuals,
people who are neurologically intact,
who don't have any of the,
the anatomical problems of,
of psychopaths,
but put them into a,
a system,
a system of poorly aligned incentives and bad ideas.
And they essentially act like psychopaths.
The,
the,
the guy who got on the bus and shot Malala and the head for,
uh,
wanting to go to school.
I mean that's essentially what happened to the Taliban.
A Taliban gunman tried to assassinate a 15 year old girl for the crime of
wanting to get an education.
Most people look at that and think,
well he must,
he must have been a psychopath or he must have been crazy.
And I think the situation we are in is far more sinister than that.
He very likely was a perfectly normal person per and very likely a father who
thought he was doing a good thing.
And in every other moment in his life it was probably a nice guy.
Probably a compassionate guy,
probably a guy who's capable of empathy jump.
Why would you know that?
Well,
because you just have to look at the kinds of atrocities that normal people
perpetrate Ian in mass movements that are,
for want of a better word,
evil.
So you let me look at Nazi Germany.
How was the,
how did the Holocaust occur?
It was not that there were hundreds of thousands of eager to collaborate in the
destruction of a people.
There were a lot of normal people who given the requisite ideas and the
requisite incentives.
And,
and,
and the,
the ability as you described to dehumanize the other just saw no prom.
And they could,
they could,
they could burn people in gas chambers by day and go home and,
and shed a tear over Wagner at night and play with their own kids and that,
that disjunction morally,
uh,
never had to be inspected.
Now obviously there's some people who are racked by guilt and some people who
refuse to collaborate.
But,
um,
I mean this is one of the scary features of the human mind.
It's possible to be an otherwise good person and do horrible things in the right
situation.
And that's not to say that there aren't psychopaths who,
who are evil and,
and essentially monsters,
but,
but normal people are capable of terrible things.
And in the context of certain religious ideas,
I think it becomes quite rational for them to,
to,
to perpetrate evil.
I agree with you,
but I don't think there's any evidence that this guy was like a normal,
nice guy in everyday life.
I just don't understand why you would assume he was.
I know it is assumed that if everyone knew that she was going to school and
there were so many people that knew it would take an extreme version of that
ideology in order to get on a bus and shoot a 15 year old girl since a little
kid.
Well,
I,
so let me just say,
I know nothing about this particular person.
I'm just guessing.
But,
uh,
I think there's no reason to believe that,
every member of the Taliban or every member of al Qaeda is a psychopath or
isn't,
is a person who would otherwise do terrible things to innocent strangers.
Um,
I,
there's,
there's no reason to believe that.
And there's,
there are many reasons to believe otherwise,
and you can just look at how people get radicalized and,
um,
it's not,
you don't have to,
you don't have to round up all the Jeffrey Dahmers of the world and,
and brainwash them and turn them loose.
It's,
they're far more functional people than that.
Um,
isn't that what we do when we train troops?
Well,
we,
yeah,
we do it.
You can even go into a more,
um,
uh,
Eh,
a stranger direction in that way.
When you look at what a surgeon has to do just to cut into a human body,
there's a kind of desensitization desensitization and,
and a,
a shutting down of empathy that the kind of normal circuits of empathy and
compassion,
uh,
to do that.
So,
so you and I,
in the presence of the suffering we would see in an,
in an er say would probably be a physiologically and emotionally really,
um,
uh,
over amped up because it,
we're not used to it and we just,
we can't,
you know,
we see someone in tears with,
a major wound
or a broken arm and all of our empathy circuits kick in.
And we're not very useful in that circumstance.
I mean,
leave aside for the moment that we actually don't know what to do.
Uh,
even if we did know what to do,
the,
the a and e flux of empathy in that moment is not especially useful and you to
be a great,
you know,
trauma surgeon.
You want to be somebody who is not distracted by the tiers and,
and you know,
the,
the obvious signs of human suffering and who can just deal with this like a
machine that has to be fixed.
Uh,
and there's,
there's something,
there's even a point of contact between that ability just to kind of shut out
the other human stuff and deal with the machine that is,
is on a continuum with this,
this cognitive emotional gesture of dehumanizing the other.
Um,
and just,
just seeing no,
no moral implication in just blowing up bodies.
I see what you're saying.
So it's essentially you're talking about a broad spectrum of possibilities of
the way the mind operates.
And there's some people that can learn how to shut things off and that's what
you're doing when you're a soldier.
You just learn how to,
this is your new reality.
Um,
there was,
uh,
an article recently where they interviewed that guy who,
who's a soldier who got in trouble because he was urinating on a dead insurgent
and they interviewed him.
And it was really interesting because he was very honest about how he felt about
the situation.
He said that people have this idea of what they want.
Adam a marine,
they want a guy who's on the commercial who slides the sword into the holster or
the scabbard and stands up straight and is wearing a perfectly trim suit.
And you don't want a guy who's gonna piss on a dead guy,
right?
But you don't get one without the other.
You don't,
you don't get a killer.
You don't get a guy who doesn't have total disdain for the enemy.
And that's what develops.
You see your friends die,
you see those around you die.
You see these people shoot at you,
you,
you developed total disdain that it's okay to kill people,
but it's not okay to pee on them.
Gets a real weird,
and I'm not saying that it's okay to pee on people.
I'm certainly not saying that it's okay to kill people either.
But I'm saying it is weird that we get mad at one and not the other.
It's almost like there's a thing about sexuality that's,
I always found really odd.
You can't watch sex,
but you can watch graphic violence.
You can put a movie and if it's sex,
it's everything.
There's legs covering,
there's angles and you don't ever see genitals if except it's very brief and
there's no actual intercourse.
We not allowed to show intercourse.
Intercourse is somehow or another ridiculously taboo,
but we can watch people's heads explode on regular television.
The walking dead is just,
every episode is just booms slash fucking swords cut heads off and guns blow
people up and were weird.
Yeah.
And some of that weirdness can be laid at the feet of religion.
I mean there's,
there's obviously the,
the conditioning we have around sexuality has religious norms
hammered into it.
And,
um,
yeah,
it's,
uh,
it's always been strange to think that that,
very explicit violence is,
um,
something just,
just acceptable entertainment and,
uh,
any kind of sexuality,
whether it's,
you know,
objectifying or,
or obviously,
you know,
romantic and,
and,
uh,
imbued with love is,
is so charged that we have to protect people from it.
And in very careful ways.
I think the,
um,
I don't know that,
that,
that story,
but the,
the marine,
um,
I don't know whether that's true.
I think it's close to something that must be true.
What do you mean,
what part is true?
Well,
just whether,
whether you can't get one without the other.
Oh yeah.
I don't know whether you need,
um,
clearly in order to,
uh,
function in that mode of defending yourself and your buddies against the threat
of the enemy and killing the enemy wherever you find him,
um,
that is a,
uh,
that's a mode in which you can't be thinking about how the enemy has kids just
like you and is eager to get home to his wife.
And I mean,
that's,
that's just not,
that's not helps.
Uh,
and it's easy to see why that would start to get drummed out to you.
so,
um,
and it's,
I mean,
it's a huge problem that we can dehumanize other people.
Uh,
it's also a huge problem that we can be part of systems and collaborate in ways
which effectively destroy other people's lives.
And we don't even notice it.
We don't even have the mechanism by which we would notice it and we don't see,
um,
we just don't see that,
that the,
we,
there is a kind of a zero sum game here,
uh,
in the bow operating in the background,
which we are all,
we,
we can't help it participate in which leaves,
you know,
people try to eek out their survival from trash heaps in developing nations.
Uh,
and you and I wondering whether we should get the,
the IPAD air,
uh,
and there's,
there's no way to really square in,
in a,
in a moral,
ethical sense the way we use our attention in that space.
So it's a,
so it's like there's,
there's no,
there's no clear way for me to help the person on the trash heap in wherever,
Nairobi
because set just cutting another check to the Red Cross or UNICEF or Doctors
Without Borders.
That's,
you know,
while,
while that's a good thing to do,
uh,
it's this sort of telescopic philanthropy where it's,
there's not a,
not a real connection that it's not a real imperative,
you know,
so when I get a mailing from a charity,
help another person who's,
who's near starvation in,
in East Africa,
uh,
my failure to do it,
my disinclination to do it.
My sense that I've got better things to do than open this junk mail never shows
up in,
in my mind or in,
in my conversation with anyone else as a shocking misuse of my resources.
And that this is not,
this is,
this is a what I'm,
what I'm in a very loose way.
I'm sketching a,
um,
a series of thought experiments that,
that people like the philosopher Peter Singer and Peter Unger have,
um,
uh,
put in,
um,
really blisteringly clear ways where you,
where,
where
we all seem to justify to ourselves,
um,
by default is living in a way where we,
we,
we care about our own happiness to a much,
much greater degree than we could possibly justify in the presence of someone
else's abject suffering.
And because we're not in the presence,
I mean,
if,
if after this podcast,
you will,
you and I walk out onto the sidewalk and see someone's starving to death in
front of us,
see it,
you know,
a child starving to death,
we wouldn't be able to ignore it.
There's just no,
it's just a clearly as our responsibility to figure out,
you know,
we,
we have to call the authorities.
We have to get some food.
We have to get a blanket,
we have to do something.
Um,
but because it's happening in another society and w and the only evidence of it
that,
that has been thrust in our face at this moment is an appeal by email or a
letter.
Just hitting delete doesn't,
doesn't strike us as the,
as analogous to stepping over the body of a child on the sidewalk and say,
saying the saying it's not our problem.
And it really,
in a global society,
it is analogous.
And yet we don't have the mechanisms in place to make it,
um,
friction free for us to feel the imperative,
uh,
and care about suffering and elsewhere.
And we,
and we have to clearly we have to figure out how to do that as a species.
Yeah,
it is.
It's almost overwhelming.
Well,
it's not almost overwhelming.
It's totally overwhelming.
The,
the sheer numbers,
you'll look at the amount of people in Africa that have aids look at,
you know,
the amount of people in Third World countries that are struggling to find food
every day.
It's the sheer numbers.
When you look at India,
there's a billion people in India.
It doesn't like,
I think 500 million or something live in total poverty.
Something crazy like that.
I mean,
I just made that number up totally probably.
Right.
It's not,
not far off.
It's probably right.
Um,
but that,
that seems like Cobb,
yeah,
I'm just going to go to the fucking store.
I don't know if I have time to do this.
I got to take care of my kids.
I got to go to dance class.
You know,
it's like there's,
at a certain point in time,
it seems like it's not your responsibility.
There's these diffusion of responsibility that comes in large numbers that
allows people to ignore a rape if there's a hundred people around and not if
there's one.
Right.
You know,
they've talked about that before.
Like people can watch people get robbed in Times Square and not do anything
about it because they're surrounded by other people.
They're waiting for someone else to a move.
It's okay to be a coward,
but if you alone in the woods and you saw some man beating some woman to death,
you would feel compelled to try to do something.
Yeah.
Well actually to,
to segue to questions of self defense.
I think that that diffusion of responsibility idea has been oversold because I
think,
yeah,
I think more of what's going on for people is they don't want to be the first
one to get stabbed.
You know,
many of those situations,
you've got somebody with a weapon.
It's not just a guy as a guy with a knife.
Um,
and uh,
and especially in that case,
the original case,
the Kitty Kitty Genovese case where,
um,
uh,
that notion of diffusion of responsibility was coined.
You had a guy with a knife stabbing a woman to death on a sidewalk,
um,
over the course of many minutes.
And there were many witnesses.
Uh,
but the,
the problem from the point of view of the herd is the first guy to rush the guy
with a knife is very likely going to get stabbed and terribly injured or killed.
And maybe the second guy is too.
But if five people rushed him at the same time,
if there was some sort of,
you know,
tactical intelligence in the group,
very likely he could be taken down and,
and neutralized.
And that would,
and you know,
maybe someone would still get hurt,
but it's not going to be like one guy after the other getting a fatal stabbing.
Um,
and that's,
uh,
it's just,
it's a problem we have in that people are frozen in people freeze and no one
wants to be,
I mean,
we don't have this,
we don't have the knowledge tactically,
uh,
among untrained people that if you all go in at once,
you have a very good shot at bringing down,
even a very scary looking guy.
You know,
if you take,
if you hit him low and I hit them high and another and another person hits him
in the middle,
it doesn't matter who he is.
You know,
if he's got 380 people,
100,
180 pound guys hitting him,
um,
it's,
uh,
we're going to bring him down.
And,
um,
you know,
obviously we have training and that's a,
that's all the more likely,
but it's what we need in,
in situations like that are people who are going to take responsibility for the
safety of others.
You know,
the,
the innocent bystander or whether you're talking about bullying in schools among
10 year olds or you're talking about crime in public,
it's the fact that we're,
we're so willing to be just bystanders.
Um,
that's,
that's a,
a problem that creates a lot of suffering.
Well,
in this soft society that we have,
our society is so soft and nice and it's the easiest society that's ever
existed.
There's not a lot of conflict and people's lives and new things like conflict or
terrifying,
especially physical conflict with another human being wants to hurt you.
It's absolutely horrifying.
I've told the story in the podcast,
but I'll tell it again for you.
I was watching a guy,
it was at the comedy store and there was two guys arguing and they were in the
middle of the street across from the House of Blues
and they started arguing.
I don't know what happened.
I just,
I saw it in the middle of it and they start swinging at each other and it was a
white guy in a black guy and the white guy just went into full panic mode and
was literally standing square and just flailing,
closing,
closing his eyes with his open hands flailing.
And then a bus pulled in front and I couldn't see them anymore.
And then as soon as the bus moved,
he was unconscious.
I didn't see what happened to him.
That's very cinematic.
Yeah,
it was.
It was.
It really was.
But I've never forgot that because I saw,
I knew what it was.
Cause I've seen people fall apart before.
You know,
I've seen it,
I've seen it in much lower levels in fights,
but to see it in that this street fight I've seen in competition,
I've seen people be intimidated and not perform to their ability or be paralyzed
by the moment.
It's a lot of people don't know what to do when the shit hits the fan.
We never have to,
we don't have any character.
But the truth is you don't,
even 10 people don't really know what have to do with what the hell would they
have to do it.
As long as they're going to all rush in at the same moment and just warm the guy
that's a good idea on paper and get 10 people together.
Hey,
who's with me?
We got attacked.
This guy picked you.
Come back to me.
I'm just telling you,
I'm not going to go near that guy.
He's going to stab me.
He still got to stab us.
We all go together,
but he's comes running after it.
I'll,
I'll tell you where the rules have changed or people's intuitions of change.
It's at 30,000 feet on an airplane.
That's true.
And we haven't really,
we haven't decided this.
It hasn't,
it hasn't come about from the top.
This has come about organically,
but I think we all have the sense that if something starts going down on an
airplane,
we're all going to rush the guy and this just going to be no hesitation because
we know how bad that can turn out.
Um,
and that is a,
uh,
I think that attitude could be brought down to ground level.
And so when you're talking about,
and you know,
an active shooter situation in a movie theater,
uh,
the fact that everyone has just run,
everyone's running away from the guy,
uh,
and,
it's just that he basically has as much time as he wants to just pick targets
and reload.
That is what makes it a circumstance of just a massacre.
But in principle,
if everyone rush the guy,
it was some people would get shot,
but it's,
you're,
you're not talking about a half hour with a guy stalking the halls,
uh,
assassinating people here.
You're talking about someone who got off a few shots and then was covered with
bodies.
Uh,
so yeah,
you always wonder,
you know,
what you would do in that scenario.
Everybody has,
and be loosened broiler and helping them.
To me,
if I see that shit,
I'm going off of that dude.
But real conflict,
I've seen it many,
many times.
You know,
I've seen thousands of guys get beat up,
like real up close.
You're going and you're talking about in compensation.
Yeah,
yeah.
And competition and it's,
um,
conflict is fucking
terrifying for people.
You know,
I've seen plenty of people get beat up on the street too,
but there's something about the potential for things to happen badly to you that
are absolutely horrifying for people.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's not that it's,
it is rational to be the first person to run away.
It's not,
it's not that that's bad advice for the person.
Um,
and it's probably advice that we should all take if our only concern is to avoid
violence wherever it appears.
And that's,
you know,
and,
and there are situations where you're going to want to do that no matter who you
are.
So if you're,
if you're out in public with your,
your six year old daughter,
um,
that's probably not the moment for you to try to be a hero.
That's the moment for you to get the hell out of there as quickly as possible.
Uh,
and that's,
that may be true.
Even if you're a cop,
you know,
you,
you have to rank,
order your priorities and do it very quickly.
But,
um,
I just think that there is,
there's an ethic that we could have much more of in the society they could,
could be tuned up by,
I mean,
it would certainly be tuned up by martial arts training in,
in many more people,
but it could just be tuned up even without the training that,
uh,
things are a lot worse when you give the bad guy amaryllis freedom to move.
Uh,
and,
and there are very few bad guys,
even armed bad guys who can deal with a crowd.
Uh,
and,
and so when these things go down in public and you have a natural crowd,
if everyone's just running away or clinging to the exits,
um,
it's,
it's very different than if,
if we all,
um,
took,
uh,
the responsibility of being the first to take them down.
I think that martial arts should be taught in school the same way we teach
writing.
The same way we teach math.
I really do.
I think if you wanted to avoid bullies,
void people become bullies,
teach people how to fight,
cause people to compete,
all that bully stuff will go away.
Bolinas is mostly born out of insecurity,
mostly born out of insecurity and born out of this desire that animals have.
Um,
you know,
to assert their dominance.
You know,
and you see in the animal world you see a constantly and people,
it's almost like a natural reaction to try to gain some security by making
others feel weak.
It's a terrible answer to this conundrum of,
you know,
of,
of insecurity.
I think a far better one is not being unsecure.
Learning that the actual martial arts techniques and learning what your
character is all about,
learning how to do something that's really difficult.
Learning how to push your body when you want to quit learning how to escape a
situation that looked hopeless.
Those things are regular lessons in a martial arts class.
Yeah.
I can't tell you how many times I've almost tapped and then gotten out of
something and you're like,
Woo.
And then you learn,
you learn how to not tap.
You learn how to get,
you know,
and tap when you have to.
Don't get injured,
but you learn how to keep calm and not freak out.
Whereas,
um,
I've been in class before with new guys and it's really,
it doesn't,
I don't,
it doesn't happen very often.
I'm really broke with white belts very often,
but I would roll with them and he would feel him panicking.
You'd feel them go into full panic attack.
You could feel them like hyperventilating,
you know,
and I'm always,
I'm the guy who's always like,
just chill out.
Relax dude,
this is what you need to do.
And I'll try to talk him through it.
But it's a weird thing to see this,
this natural animal reaction simply because the person is not trained.
Or I'll be in that same position with a guy who's like a blue belt or something
like that and they just stay calm.
They know how to do it.
They've been there,
done that.
They know how to do it and they might get tapped still,
but at least they're gonna do what they have to do to,
to try their best to get out of that situation.
I think that martial arts for men especially,
and I think for women too,
I shouldn't even say men,
especially a,
and obviously don't know what it's like to be a woman.
But I think for men it's a critical part of developing your personality,
not because you should be fighting people,
not because you should be,
I think people need to do difficult things to explore their character.
I think it's important for human beings.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I completely agree.
I think we'd want to distinguish between or among the martial arts because I
think there are martial arts that,
that tune up the wrong part of the ego because you're actually not ever having
your skills confirmed or disconfirmed cause it's all in the,
in this,
in this domain of fantasy and pantomimes of violence.
And um,
just very quiet.
Just this,
we have this,
this cooperative exchange of attacks and,
and replies to the attacks where you're not actually fighting,
right?
You're not actually poking the person in the eye and seeing what's,
what happens or getting poked in the eye sight.
So these,
this sort of the cut between,
uh,
you know,
what are either either the fantasy based martial arts or the or the,
uh,
so-called,
um,
realistic,
you know,
self defense,
martial arts and something like Brazilian Jujitsu where where you're really,
you're,
you're pressure testing it 100%.
Uh,
now I think,
I think there,
there are,
uh,
pathologies to the sport pressure testing as well.
I think you have to have a,
to get a very clear view of what,
what works in the world.
You have to be a,
an intelligent consumer of all these things.
But there is something toxic about training in a,
an art where you're always left wondering whether it works.
Yes.
You know,
and,
and especially as a teenage male if the feeling that you might have something to
prove and the fear of,
of being someone who couldn't actually prove it.
And that whole paranoia that happens in a school where you have teachers who,
who skills are by definition never tested it.
Like the black belt.
A sensei never is going to roll with his students in these arts.
I mean,
all he's doing is walking around teaching his fantasy techniques,
uh,
and you,
you need,
you'd never,
I,
the students wouldn't be comfortable,
you know,
wrestling him the ground and it's,
sweating,
tapping him out.
It was just,
you know,
you have this,
this hierarchy that is never,
um,
uh,
it,
it's,
you just imagine that the guys got mad skills,
but it's,
they're never,
they're never demonstrated in a way that is,
other than,
you know,
yeah.
Maybe he can do some very pretty kicks,
but he's not actually fighting anyone.
It's very cold.
Like when I was doing taekwondo,
when I was a kid,
it was very cold.
Like,
I mean,
there was,
uh,
we,
we showed that it was effective against taekwondo and training,
but they didn't take advantage of the call.
It was a very good school and it was just about discipline.
And for me it was hugely important to have that discipline as a young man,
the bowing and all that stuff.
There's rules that you just don't cross.
Like,
I remember when I was,
um,
when I was 15,
I had a crazy girlfriend and uh,
she used to want to choose to want to do it all the time.
She was crazy and she wants to do it at the school cause I was teaching at the
time.
I used to have the keys to the school and I wouldn't,
I wouldn't let her,
I mean that's the only time ever,
the only rule that could have prevented you from doing that,
especially as a horny 15,
16 year old,
whatever it was.
That's ridiculous.
You know?
I mean,
I had a lock keyed what building and no one was there and we could just bang it
out.
No problem.
There's couches.
There was no problems.
I was like,
nope,
we can't do it here.
You know?
And I'd never had any discipline whatsoever as a young man.
But I remember when I started learning it,
taekwondo,
it was like very limited.
There was a lot of holes in it as a style,
especially when it comes to punching.
Like taekwondo is all about kicking.
There's benefits to that because he learned like really incredible leg dexterity
in some of the best kickers ever.
Our taekwondo guys who eventually learned Moyie Thai kickboxing,
boxing and wrestling,
right?
There's a lot of guys in the UFC now that,
that are super effective with those techniques.
But when you start training with kickbox is you just get beat up.
It's a really humbling revelation.
I realized,
Oh fuck,
you know,
I've been wasting time.
Like I'm doing something.
Like I had to revamp my whole style.
I completed that and then I started kickboxing and then I thought,
well at least I've got,
you know,
that whole patched up.
And then I went to Jujitsu class and I got fucking mangled and I was like,
oh no,
I'm helpless.
I was like,
at least I thought like in a street fight with striking,
even if I wasn't like the best kicker,
a puncher that,
so I would be able to keep some the off of me.
But I,
there's this kid that was a purple belt,
this Brazilian kid who's just just raped me.
He was just run through me,
just smash me every time we train.
I had never had a chance and he wasn't trying to let me survive.
He was getting great delight.
He was about my age,
great delight,
and strangle the shit out of me,
and it was a very important,
because I could quit,
I could quit.
Then I could've said,
you know what?
Fuck this.
I'll just go to a kickboxing Jenny Moore.
I'm proficient and I look good.
I'm not doing this where I just get humiliated.
Anybody's watching and I look like a bitch,
but I decided I want to do what he's doing.
I want to be able to do that.
That's incredible.
This guy just manhandled me.
Wear the same size and you can do anything he wants to make.
It tapped me.
He was mounting me.
Armbar me triangling mean it was just running through drills on me.
I was like,
this is ridiculous.
Yeah.
It's such an astonishing epiphany as a,
I mean,
it's probably true for anyone,
but it's especially true if you've come from a background in martial arts where
you think you have some skills.
Did you?
Yeah,
yeah.
What was your background?
So I,
I studied with a guy,
um,
uh,
as a teenager through maybe a,
I think I stopped when I was 22 and this is a guy whose,
whose background I never totally believed.
I mean as he's like,
he had real skills and he taught something that was a very analogous to Krav
Maga or somebody said it's like a street oriented self defense where you're
learning,
you're basically taking the boxing,
the striking from boxing and the kicking from Muay Thai and a just a Smidgen of
grappling.
But I basically did not know how to grapple,
but I,
I felt like I knew a lot about how to defend myself.
Right.
Uh,
but I hadn't done martial arts for 20 years and I get back into it,
uh,
and start doing Brazilian Jujitsu and got on the mat with Chris Hauder and it
was like,
it was like wrestling with a Martian.
I mean it was just,
it was just like that the rules of physics did not apply to him.
And He's,
he's my son.
He's probably 10 pounds lighter than me.
He's,
he's,
and maybe an inch shorter.
And,
um,
it was just this most surreal experience of being,
of making a hundred percent effort to survive and failing every 30 seconds or a
minute and a half.
And just then being resurrected by just the sheer fact that he decided not to
kill me.
And,
and then doing it again and just gat and it,
there's nothing like gassing under that kind of pressure when you have no idea,
you have no idea what to do and you have no idea to relax.
It's like this,
like you can't,
it's,
you can't.
So awesome.
Yeah.
And Chris Helder is old school Machado.
Black belt.
He's been around for a long time.
Yeah,
he's a,
I think he was wanting to,
John Chalk or Hagens,
I don't know who is under his,
the only Gagan he get a gun when he gets first black boats.
He's,
yeah,
he's got some skills.
He's one of the,
I think they,
I think they're called the dirty dozen,
I think the first 12 American black belts.
And he's one of the,
he's one of the first
as one of the,
uh,
without a doubt,
one of the greatest compliments my life.
Yeah.
When I got my five belt there was snowed out.
That's awesome.
It's like,
wow,
whoa.
And is it hard to believe,
you know,
it's like,
whoa.
You know,
when,
when I can do that to people,
that's the weirdest thing ever.
And when I can do what that purple belt did mean,
I don't do it.
I'm not mean like that,
but the,
when I can just,
just play with somebody.
It's so funny.
It's so strange.
It's like,
and then people can play with me.
Like if I roll the Jake shields or Marcella Garcia or Eddie Bravo,
they just,
mommy,
I mean,
this is,
I'm doing this survive.
And if I wrote with Eddie Bravo,
it's just survival.
John Jack,
same thing.
Survival.
Trying to survive,
trying to hang on survival,
try to use defense.
And John Jack goes easy on you.
He's like,
my man,
look out for your mom.
You know,
he,
he jokes around with you as he's rolling with you.
Right.
But,
um,
the,
uh,
the technical aspect of Jujitsu is very overlooked to people who don't
participant in it because it's weird when you looking at it,
it's just a bunch of guys swimming around in the ground like they don't
understand it.
I remember watching the original UFC,
he's before I started Jujitsu,
look like,
what is he doing?
I got understand what he's doing.
I didn't understand the movement.
So I was seeing was the end right where I take great pride in when I do
commentary explaining the various steps that the guy has to do.
Like this is what he's got to do and this is what he's got to avoid.
Like there's two things going on right now.
There's a battle of position and I've had so many people come up to me that said
they started Jujitsu based on listening to the commentary.
They're like,
I gotta learn this.
This is so cool.
It's so weird.
And it's one of the few martial arts where the little man really can defeat the
bigger,
stronger man easily.
And there's a lot of that,
that fantasy martial arts that you were talking about where there's people that
have the deaf touch and they can,
you know what I mean?
You've seen those videos online where guys throw their hand and people and they
fall to the ground and you've got an a wonder what's going on,
whether the person's helping out and they're falling to the ground on purpose or
whether they really believe they get zapped with some cheap.
But when you see a guy like hoists Gracie defeat a guy like Ken shamrock or
defeat a guy like,
um,
like the old school Dan Severen.
Yeah.
When you called him in that triangle off his back,
he taps him.
I mean madness.
Like how does this happen?
How is this possible?
This guy's 250 fucking pounds.
The other guys,
one 70,
soaking wet bill like a popsicle stick.
And he just,
he just tapped that guy.
He gave up.
Yeah.
It's so technical,
you know?
And so it's really the,
the one martial art that actually has that whole Bruce Lee thing going on where
the one small guy can defeat the large guy.
It's all,
it's also the one art where
it has what a Kido claims it has.
It really is it at least potentially the peaceful art?
Yeah,
you can,
it's just a negotiation.
I mean you,
you control someone's position,
you control someone's ability to harm you and then you can just start talking
like how far do you want to take this?
Exactly.
And,
and it's,
uh,
Eh,
in principle all grappling is that,
and all,
you know,
joint locks added to grappling I guess,
uh,
is that,
but Brazilian Jujitsu is,
I think the,
uh,
if you're just going to take the off the shelf solution to that suite of
problems where you've got two people trying to dominate one another physically
and you want to do it in a way where the violence is truly incremental,
where you do,
you can just,
you can turn it up as slowly as,
as the,
the laws of physics allow,
uh,
Brazilian Jujitsu is,
is that,
and whereas a striking based solution is not that mean you don't know what's
going to happen when you punch someone in the face.
You,
you,
you may break your hand,
you may knock them out.
You may knock them out and have them hit their head on the curb and die.
There's a lot,
there's a lot you can't control for and you,
and you can't,
I mean,
you can't apply a punch incrementally,
uh,
to,
to solve the problem.
And so it's,
um,
and they can hit you too.
Yeah.
When you're grappling
with a guy.
If,
if I get a guy down in my,
mount them and he's a white belt,
he's not choking me.
Right?
It's not gonna happen.
Right.
But if you're swinging with some guy out in the parking lot,
you could easily get knocked.
Oh yeah.
I've seen fights in the UFC where a high level striker gets KOD by a guy who has
no business in the ring with them.
It just happens.
You guys swings a punch.
He connects on the draw and that's a wrap.
Yeah,
there's not a lot of luck and grappling.
Zero,
zero luck.
And that's what's amazing about it.
It's,
I mean,
no one ever says he got a lucky triangle.
He can't get a lucky tree.
That's a fucking complex move to set up.
You have to cut angles,
you have to secure it.
You have to make sure it's not over the foot.
It's over the ankle.
There's a lot of lot of variables involved.
You're a,
you were talking about your instructor not quite believing in him.
Eddie Bravo has a great story of a guy that he was training under before he
found Jujitsu that was doing one of those sort of multiple art bait systems.
He had like,
you know,
five black belts and different arts and he told everyone he was going to China
to train.
You know,
he had a great master in China that he was going to train and uh,
Eddie went to the supermarket and you recognize the guy's car.
And so he goes inside and the guy was shopping.
He was pretending he was in China.
He just took the week off and was just hanging out and shopping.
Who's going to come back and tell everybody went to China and learn some cheap
gone.
Have you seen those videos online where they have those old masters to think
that they can actually fight?
Yeah,
no,
I have,
I posted a bunch of those on my youtube page.
There's so sad there.
Well,
there the sad one.
What were the guy offers the challenge and then gets punched in the nose by the,
this very ordinary looking martial artists,
um,
that,
that one's sad,
but the,
the,
I mean they just mesmerizing to watch the ones where there is no dis
confirmation.
There's just the,
just the cult in full.
Yeah.
Uh,
splendor and you just have everyone complying with this magic touch.
I mean,
even at distances of 20 feet,
you got people,
you know,
writhing in pain and flopping around.
Uh,
and I don't,
I don't know what explains it.
I don't think it is conscious fraud on the part of most of these people.
I think there's a,
there's a kind of induction is that there's a sort of,
there's a hypnotic component to it and a sort of a suggestibility but,
and also social pressure and self deception and,
and just many things get,
get a conspired to make people participate in this thing that is seemingly the
most delusional thing that has ever happened.
Explained to people who have no idea what we're talking about.
Okay.
So that you can actually,
um,
uh,
a good place to see it.
We have a video po yeah.
On,
on,
um,
on my,
uh,
if you go to my youtube page,
there's a,
there's a fake martial art stream,
uh,
and uh,
Sam Harris or,
or gee is my,
is my youtube page,
but there's,
um,
and also I wrote a blog post,
the,
um,
the pleasures of drowning where I talked about a Brazilian Jujitsu.
And in that blog post,
I think it's an Epilogue,
I'm pretty sure isn't that blog post I linked to one of these videos.
Um,
uh,
the,
um,
like he bills himself as some,
a kito master.
I,
okay.
I can't imagine he's actually an Aikido guy,
but this is the guy who is causing people to fly all over the room at a distance
of 20 feet.
And then he issues this challenge.
And I think it was a $5,000 challenge to any martial artists who had the courage
to test his powers.
And you see the challenge match where,
um,
on,
no,
this is,
um,
these guys are also awesome.
These guys are amazing.
Yeah.
It just throws him off.
So,
uh,
there,
there are many,
there's so many,
there's so many videos out there that are,
are just priceless and they should be impossible.
I mean,
this is really,
this is not because this is just,
it has all the features of religion except the thing that,
that's the guy.
Oh yeah.
Cause yeah,
he's the guy who's got a,
so you see his skills.
This is,
this is where his has skills work.
Um,
but then you see a challenge match.
And uh,
he,
he clearly did not know that he couldn't do this because otherwise he would
never would have issued that challenge.
But he really believes that this is working.
This is working.
But you can imagine what if you opened a school and for the next 30 years,
everyone cooperates with you.
You know,
so you've never met someone who wouldn't fall down a w two,
your magic touch.
I,
you could see how he would believe this.
And he's basically run a psychological experiment on himself and brainwashed
himself in the presence of all of these compliance students.
Um,
but anyways,
challenge matches is,
um,
somewhat depressing,
but also it's also pretty satisfying to see a mass delusion disconfirmed that
emphatically,
I mean that this is what you want to see go down with religion.
The problem is the,
the religion really is tennis without a net.
I mean there's just,
there is no,
there's no discount formation that is so clear that the religious person is
going to accept it.
Whereas this guy getting repeatedly punched in the face,
he has to accept that he's lost the fight.
I'm a one imagines maybe he still has a school somewhere,
but um,
it's just,
it's clear that his,
his martial art doesn't work well.
He gets so confused when he gets hit.
You could see the look on his face,
see,
play it through the part where you get the beat up.
He gets so confused.
Pull it like it's way ahead.
Where he's a,
there's a,
looks like a,
a Keel,
Kachin guy who's wearing a pair of shorts.
Yeah.
This is the guy.
Some sort of mean.
Just imagine if he got in there with,
with the Anderson Silva.
Anderson Silva is someone who really wanted to prove a point.
I mean,
the guy he is with hears is just Joe,
Joe Karate guy,
skilled though the,
when he did a really smart thing,
he grabbed his gay,
he grabbed his ski and just started wailing on him in the face.
He punched him three or four times.
Then he kicked him in the face and he's an old man.
But,
but also you see the,
in the other video you see that this guy really doesn't want to hurt him.
He's,
he's worried about hurting him.
And so after the first blow land,
that's it right there.
That's,
that's post first blow.
Right before that,
he hits him for the first time and he stops right there.
There's another angle on this.
There's a video shot from the other side where you can see,
um,
kick while he's holding onto his arm.
Yeah.
We can't even move.
He just holds them in there and punch him in the face.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's a,
it's amazing.
I mean,
this is,
this is the,
uh,
the perfect look I the perfect window at what the human mind is capable of.
So,
so if the fact that human minds can do this proves that religion can be every
bit as delusional as atheists say,
it is a,
or at least the,
the,
the doctrines about the afterlife and,
you know,
all the garish stuff that,
that,
uh,
we think of in terms of religion,
it can,
it's,
it's so much easier to deceive yourself about that than it is to deceive
yourself.
That you can knock,
you know,
20 opponents down with your magic touch.
And yet this is possible when you have a mechanism,
what's going on there is you're a neuroscientist.
Tell me what's happening in a person's mind that allows them to just accept like
hypnotism.
That's real,
right?
It is real.
I,
you know,
[inaudible] there's,
there's a frontier between what's real and what,
uh,
and just,
just what I,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't know where fraud starts and genuine demonstrations of hypnosis and,
and,
and so,
um,
but clearly some people,
and there's a spectrum of,
of suggestibility.
Some people are not hypnotizable.
It's not sounding like everyone can,
can be,
um,
you know,
the Manchurian candidate.
But,
uh,
there's,
there clearly it's clearly a phenomenon where you can be given a,
uh,
a,
you can be inducted into a state where you're given suggestions,
which then are operative at the level of your behavior and emotion and,
um,
and about what you may have no recollection.
Uh,
so I think hypnosis is,
is,
is real.
Um,
and it's a,
uh,
there's also,
there's other features to this.
So there's the social pressure.
I mean,
so it just meant,
and then just the sunk cost.
I mean,
imagine devoting years of your life to something which does not work.
Um,
but pays all you have the,
either the,
these,
the belongingness to the group.
You have all of the,
you know,
all of the,
uh,
the rituals and,
um,
uh,
just the sunk cost of how much time you've spent doing this thing,
whether it's religion or a fake martial art.
Uh,
the,
the pressure that,
the emotional pressure not to realize it's bullshit is it can be excruciating.
And,
and when you meet people,
I mean,
well,
one of the,
one of my favorite conversations with a,
a former person to faith that I've ever had was,
um,
I met someone at dinner who had lost her faith that day.
Literally,
I got her just fresh,
you know,
that,
that just adjust when the thought bubble had had burst.
Uh,
she,
she just showed up at this dinner and the,
her overriding,
uh,
feeling was just of,
depression over how much time she had wasted.
Just like the sunk cost of it because she had spent decades fixated on this,
this stuff,
and it had,
it had completely distorted her relationships and him,
it had been the center of her life.
And she finally admitted to herself that day that in this case with Catholicism,
that none of it was true.
You know,
and this is what she had just been brainwashed.
Uh,
and,
but,
but the,
the,
the regret,
the level of regret over the time wasted and all the things she could have done
with that time and all the,
uh,
it's just,
it's,
that is a wall that,
that many people just can't clear because it's,
it's just too painful to acknowledge.
It's very painful.
When,
what was the mechanism for her?
What was the,
the,
the reason,
uh,
well,
actually it should be,
she credited one of my books in that she may be something else that had,
had helped her along,
but no,
the last thing she had been reading where she finally realized,
Oh my God,
I've been deceived about this.
Uh,
it was,
what was one of my books hoodwinked?
Was it letters to a Christian nation?
I don't know.
It was either that or the interface.
Lying is your new book and what it's,
uh,
there's a really important thing that you,
you bring up and it's not on the front part of this.
I read it online somewhere that you can avoid a lot of problems in your life.
Yeah.
Simply by not lying.
Almost almost all of them.
Of all the ones that are avoidable.
Yeah.
When you just look at how people screw up their lives line is,
if it's not the reason,
it's the thing that enabled the other reason it's people complicate their lives
massively by a willingness to deceive others.
Uh,
and to,
and this has many features to it.
One is just there all the things you,
you can do based on the cover that lies provide that you shouldn't be doing
because they're not good for you and know,
and everyone would hate you if they knew you were doing them or your,
you know,
your wife would leave you or whatever,
whatever it is.
Uh,
and so the law,
the lies,
lies create a space in which you can let your life run off the whale.
Oh,
run off the rails,
whether it's becoming an addict or what,
or,
um,
uh,
you know,
perpetrating financial frauds or whatever it is.
Uh,
uh,
but there's,
there's also this component where you don't actually,
you never actually discover who you are in social space if you always leave
yourself this out of line.
So it's like you never discover that if you keep canceling plans with people and
just tell this white lie that you're too busy or you're not feeling well or you
never have to confront the fact that these are people you actually don't want to
see.
You know,
you don't feel like you've got people in your life who want to go out to dinner
with you.
You don't want to see them and you're never having to confront that because you
have this out that you're just going to lie,
you know?
And,
and it's just if you want,
I mean,
there's actually no change in a person's life that I think is more important in
terms of getting your life straight,
your,
your relationship to ship straight.
You're just getting into the future,
uh,
without screwing it up for yourself.
Um,
there's no more important change then,
then a commitment to being honest and in,
in whatever the situation is that presents itself.
So you don't fake it till you make it.
That's not good.
Do you ever heard that?
Well,
no,
you can
not good that I think,
well you can fake,
you can fake something until you make it,
which is you can fake confidence,
a positive attitude toward uncertainty.
I mean you can,
so you can,
so you can go into a situation without any guarantee that it's going to work out
or that you're going to develop the skills that you need or that you are going,
that people are going to like you but have a positive attitude.
Uh,
and,
and um,
I mean it's sort of a good will toward the future that you can develop.
And that is a kind of,
I mean it's,
it's faking confidence and faking comfort.
Maybe,
but that's not lying.
That's a line is,
is when you are intent intentionally
implant planting false beliefs and others when they expect the truth.
So it's not,
I mean it's so,
so being a card magician or being a poker player,
I mean this is not,
this is not lying.
That's not decided.
I mean,
the deception I'm talking about is when someone has every reason to expect the
truth and you are purporting to give the truth,
but you're not,
and you're actually deceiving them.
Um,
and,
uh,
what I focus on in the book,
because it,
most virtually everyone recognizes that some subset of,
of deceptions are a problem.
I mean,
the agregious lives that,
you know,
the frauds that,
that really harm people.
And the lies that,
you know,
when a pharmaceutical company says the drug works and they're lying,
everyone recognizes that that's a problem that we've,
we've all paid a huge price for the,
the,
the skepticism we now have about governments and corporations because of
whenever we cashed them in a lie,
we just now,
for the next 10 years,
can't forget that these people in power often lie to us.
Uh,
but the,
uh,
the line that people,
there's,
there's a,
there's another set of,
of,
of lies that people think are actually unavoidable,
you know,
or,
or good.
Uh,
and this is,
they're usually called white lies.
Um,
and I think that,
I think the price we pay for white lies is also excruciating.
And it's not something that people are quick to see.
And actually I didn't see it until I went to,
when I was a freshman at Stanford,
I took a course with a professor who I actually interview in the back of the
book.
Um,
Ronald Howard,
who is a,
um,
really a brilliant guy who started a whole academic field called decision
analysis and the 60s.
And it's,
it's a,
um,
it's a Ma a mechanism which
allows someone to make as rational decision as possible by putting all of their
information about a topic into,
into,
uh,
essentially a calculation.
Um,
it's got nothing to do with,
with,
uh,
with line or our honesty.
But he's a,
he's a,
a,
a professor in the engineering economic systems department at Stanford and he as
kind of a sideline to his,
his academic work was teaching these,
these courses on ethics.
And one course was just on the question whether it's ever ethical to lie.
And so as a freshman I was just sort of put in the machine of this course and
came out the other side,
convinced that in virtually any situation,
apart from like a self defense situation where you would,
where things have really broken down and you're not in the presence of someone
who you're going to collaborate with line is just unacceptable.
It's just not,
it's not how I want to live.
It's not how,
um,
anyone should want to live if they look at it closely enough.
And it's really one of the huge problems that we have as a race is we,
we know how to communicate.
We know how to,
uh,
we,
like when you were talking to that rabbi that we were talking about earlier and
he has this like very eloquent and you know,
very theatrical way of communicating.
And you know,
it's,
it's kind of tricky because when someone's really good at that,
you want to believe that they're telling the truth.
You want to believe that someone who is lying to you in a very charismatic way
is telling you the truth until we actually can read each other's minds.
This is a lot of confusion that goes on in human interaction,
just bumping into each other,
just not getting anything done,
not figuring out what's really going on,
not figuring out the real relationship that you have to other people in your
life.
You know?
I know people that lie constantly and they never get their shit together.
They just have like these little lies here and they're like,
why didn't you call me back?
Ah,
this thing came up and it's always,
they just,
they and they're always in a mess.
There's just a mess and I think you're a hundred percent dead on.
I think that that,
that part,
that the be honest part,
that's one of the most critical aspects of human behavior.
We make an agreement with each other.
If you're going to be in my life,
we're going to be friends.
We have to be 100% honest with each other.
And as soon as someone's not 100% honest,
well then what percentage are your honest,
is it 90,
is it 80,
is it 70,
what do I gotta do?
I gotta throw everything through a filter.
This,
it's not worth it.
It's not worth it.
And then there's the question of whether you want to have a different ethical
code for your friends and for strangers,
right?
And then you,
you,
you run into situations where the stranger suddenly is a friend and you are now
confronted with having had a different ethical code or you discover that this
is,
this person is somebody who's brother and you just lied to them.
It's just,
it's not tenable to live this way.
And it's what I'm interested in are the,
the subtle ways that it erodes trust between people.
Because there's just one example I use in the book where a friend was out with
her,
her girlfriend,
and she wasn't like her best friend,
but they were very close friends.
And,
um,
the girlfriend was supposed have had plans later that night with another friend.
Uh,
and didn't want to,
to have that plan.
And so this is,
you know,
a friend,
a watches,
her friend call up the third friend and lie about why she can't have plans and
she lied so convincingly and effortlessly and just it was just,
you know,
there's something with her kid being sick,
whatever it was.
And then you got off the phone and then went back to the conversation with,
with friend day and what friend day experience in that moment was just a,
a subtle but absolutely obvious erosion of trust,
like a permanent erosion of trust.
But it was,
it was something that could never be rectified because it was not,
they were not so close that she was going to perform an intervention there and
say,
look,
we know,
why are you lying and why do you do this and have you ever done this to me?
She was just left with this vague sense that probably this woman had lied to her
in the past and would lie to her in the future.
And,
and we go through life like this with people and,
and people,
the people who are,
who are telling the little lies are just,
they're never,
I mean,
so the,
the,
the liar and that case never knew that she had suddenly degraded her,
her friendship with the first friend.
Um,
and the things just don't get discovered and there it's very toxic.
I find also that people that lie or very difficult,
it seeing lies and others are very bad rather at seeing lies and others.
I think that people who are bullshitters can be bullshitted.
People were con artists can be conned.
There's a,
there's a,
there's some sort of a disconnect that people have that don't live in,
especially in introspective,
really objective version of themselves.
Like really looking hard at all their issues.
If you're lying,
you're not doing that.
So if you're not,
if you don't,
you know,
you might have some walls up that you might not know about and they could lead
to you getting lied to.
It's very possible.
Right,
right.
Oh,
to,
to go back to the,
to the rabbi though.
I think in that case he wasn't lying.
I don't,
I don't think,
I think most religious people believe what they say.
They believe in smart though.
I kind of think that's the,
that's the scary thing about it.
And that's it.
So this is not,
the,
certainly doesn't apply to a rabbi Wolpe but,
but,
uh,
this applies to the jihadist who thinks he's going to get 72 virgins in
paradise.
You can be smart and believe that.
And that's,
that's the scary thing.
You can be the engineer who could have had everything but decides to be a
jihadist because he believes that the afterlife conforms to the Quran and the
Hadoop and,
and that,
that is a,
um,
so I,
I mean,
deception is part of the game and self deception as part of the game,
but in many cases,
I think you have people who have been
indoctrinated from birth or get a message from their culture that,
or get emotionally hijacked in ways that allow them to believe the unbelievable.
And then they're being perfectly honest when they,
when they spread those ideas,
they're not,
they're not frauds.
Um,
and that's,
that I think is,
um,
so it's,
it's,
it's a different problem.
It deception is,
is self deception is certainly a component in many of these cases.
But
do you think it's possible that technology will eventually make lying obsolete?
Like what,
what we're seeing right now with this uh,
invasion of privacy thing with the NSA we're seeing in a,
it's a one sided trip obviously and then you have wiki leaks and Eric Snowden,
they're the Eric,
those name Edward Edward Edward Snowden or the or the other side releasing,
you know,
scratch bits of information that they can scratch together and smuggle out.
But it seems to me like that's where the trend is ultimately going.
The trend is ultimately going to,
you're not going to,
like,
if you send someone a picture of your Dick Online,
it's going to be out there.
Someone's going to get that.
If you,
you know,
if you send a blank,
if this happens,
if that happens,
if you know,
if it's all going to be recorded,
you've got to know where you were.
You have a gps chip on your phone or your Google glass.
It knows exactly where you were.
If records you all the time.
I think this NSA thing is fucking terrible.
I think it's terrible.
Mostly because it's the government that has all the power in this situation.
It's these people that are,
they're not using it.
I mean the idea is that they are using it to prevent terrorism.
I see.
I guess maybe,
but there's so much evidence that points to the fact they were spying on other
world leaders that they didn't think were terrorists there.
It's essentially using it as a vehicle for control and but it brings up a
fascinating new area of technology and that is this,
this new era that we're entering into where everything's getting closer and
closer and closer to the point where one day we're going to have this one
database that we all draw from all the time.
If we have the internet,
we're going to have something that it's like a pair of glasses or like something
that you were inside your skin or or something that's going to allow everybody
to be connected all over the place.
I don't know how we're going to manage it,
but all that information we're going to be able to get to it.
I'm going to be able to know what you had for lunch today.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well there's,
there's,
so there's that component.
There's the,
just the sheer transparency based on having so much data.
Uh,
yeah.
But there's this other technological fix for deception,
which is just actual lie detection.
And I think that is coming.
I think there's no question that at some point we are going to have lie
detection that where it may not be perfect,
but it will be valid enough and reliable enough that we rely on it,
uh,
in the way that we rely on DNA evidence.
So as if it's,
if it was your DNA at the scene,
you know,
we,
we think you're involved if you are caught lying as measured by this machine
where we're going to think you're lying and that's going to be,
you know,
forensically actionable.
I think that's it.
We're not,
we're certainly not there yet,
but I think that it would,
it would really surprise me if we don't get there.
I wanted to talk to you about this because I had a,
one of your colleagues on my show,
a Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
I can't remember her name right now.
Blonde woman,
Pam,
Pam Douglas,
I believe so.
I believe that was who it was.
Yeah.
And she was talking about Fmr,
I results and how a woman was actually convicted of a murder.
I believe it was in India because of Fmr.
I that she had what they called functional knowledge of the crime scene.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
See on another,
I think that strikes almost any neuroscientists as a
premature use of the technology.
Uh,
and in that case you're talking about a,
um,
I mean at that,
I think that,
I think that mode of inquiry is problematic because you're,
you're talking about just,
just familiarity with the crime scene or would it with the evidence and there
are clearly other sources of familiarity and,
and you know,
if,
if the,
if the dead girl is wearing a dress that you just bought out of the j crew
catalog,
you're familiar with the dress.
And I don't know that they have a,
I don't know that they've operationalized us in the way that that will,
will protect you from just,
just accidentally being familiar with the,
with the,
um,
uh,
some features of the crime scene,
to say nothing of the fact that we just cannot resolve brain function that clear
clearly enough to,
to,
uh,
base those kinds of decisions on,
on a judgment that the person is,
is lying or not.
Uh,
we don't understand that the,
the neural correlates of,
of honesty and deception enough to know,
but it's,
I think it would be very surprising if we never get there.
And so,
so,
and again,
we're now,
I'm just speculating if it was Pam on your bluejay hours.
Um,
she actually took,
she was a name again Pamela.
Pamela Douglas is the woman I'm thinking of.
She was like,
she was a graduate student in the lab I was in at Ucla and she,
after I did a,
um,
after I did a study of belief,
where I compared belief and disbelief and uncertainty with Smri,
uh,
she came back and re and used all of my data to look to,
to see if she could discriminate what subjects believed at the single trial
level,
which is at,
on,
on each question.
So,
so what I did is I put subjects on a scanner and I gave them propositions to
read that we either clearly true are clearly falls are clearly undecidable and
just compared belief versus disbelief versus uncertainty.
And that is if you could that,
if you could do that at the single trial level,
you essentially have a,
a lie detector.
Because if you believe that you were the person who committed the crime,
uh,
and we can,
we have a,
a understanding of the neural correlates of belief versus disbelief,
then we could easily ask you,
you know,
whether you were involved in a way that would tease that out.
So she,
she wanted to see whether we could,
uh,
see the difference between belief and disbelief and uncertainty.
Uh,
at the,
at the micro level,
just,
just a,
you know,
on a single question level and her,
her,
um,
classifiers were over 90% accurate.
So as she was,
she was over 90% in,
in guessing essentially whether someone was,
could believed or disbelieved a proposition.
Uh,
and so if you had any,
it's easy to see how we would now with available technology have a lie detector
that was 90% accurate.
Now that's not accurate enough to put people away and you know,
for,
for misstatements in court.
But if we could get it to the level of accuracy that we now rely on for DNA
evidence,
uh,
I think we would,
it's,
it's an interesting question philosophically and experimentally how we'd ever
bridged that gap and how we'd ever be truly confident that no matter what sort
of histrionics and protestations this person is lying,
this though this person is,
is,
is claims,
you know,
on his mother's life that he's telling the truth.
The brain scan evidence says otherwise.
Somehow I feel like that is going to be harder to achieve.
Then,
uh,
him saying it's not my blood is not my blood is not my blood,
but the DNA evidence says otherwise.
Um,
but in principle I don't see any reason why we couldn't get there and that,
and that I think would change things a lot because when you look at the price we
pay for not being able to determine whether someone is lying.
It is huge.
I mean,
it is,
I mean we were talking about there are people in prison for the rest of the
people who have gone to death row and been executed who we know were innocent.
You know,
the,
there's not just one.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
and,
and in the most horrific,
I mean there was this one guy whose name is now escaping me,
but,
um,
there was a new Yorker profile on him where his house burned down and he was
charged with the crime of having set the fire and killing his two kids.
Now imagine being someone whose house burned down and your two kids die in the
fire and the world thinks you did it.
And not only do they think you did it,
they prosecute you,
your defense fails,
you go to death row and you're executed right for the crime of having murdered
your children.
Um,
uh,
now that if we could just tell whether someone was telling the truth that that
problem goes away and we're,
and,
and they're,
you know,
they're,
think of,
think of the,
the implications of,
um,
you know,
negotiation among the leaders of countries where you don't know whether people
were telling the truth and we do or do not have nuclear weapons.
You don't know whether they're telling I if,
if,
if there was transparency at the level of all for all of those conversations,
it would
really be a game changer.
Not only that,
women will have to finally accept what men actually think.
We could stop bullshitting.
We could stop sex in the city and notebooking our way through this life.
Well,
that would be nice.
We'd also have to find out what women think.
It could be a revelation.
It will be awful.
Well,
it'd be great,
but you know,
for a while it'd be awful.
Do you,
what do you think that that ultimately is going to lead to the change that we
need and world governments?
Is that what the big one is going to be?
The ability to discern whether or not people are telling the truth.
Because if that set seems like just that alone would change everything.
If you could see clearly motivations,
you could see clearly benefits to certain actions.
You can clearly see deceptive tactics based on,
you know,
well,
really what they're trying to do is this,
you know,
read it out.
You know what they're actually trying to do is make money for x corporation.
They're pretending that they're trying to save the country from an evil
dictator,
but really what they're trying to do is extract resources.
Here's the clear data,
like what do we do if we have everything out on the table?
What a weird world we would live in.
It would it?
That could be the total 100% game changer.
Even bigger in fact than the Internet.
If we could find out what everybody actually thinks.
Yeah,
I,
there,
there are a few wrinkles to it.
Cause if you were self deceived,
if you actually believed what you said,
we're saying,
but you're,
what you're saying is not true,
then you can sort of game the system like a lie detector test.
Yeah.
I mean so,
so well,
you know,
if we had,
if we totally understood the,
the neural neural correlates of deception,
we wouldn't necessarily be able to detect someone who believed their own lives
and there may be some way to,
to be confused enough or confabulate stick enough about reality that you can
just bullshit or spit ball or,
or,
um,
say what you want to be true or kind of hypnotize yourself.
I mean,
we just don't actually know what's true at the level of,
of the minds.
You cognitive elasticity.
So you,
so it's,
it's possible that you could have people who are not good subjects of lie
detection in some sense.
And,
um,
that's something we could,
we would understand if we understood all this.
Uh,
but I think in the,
uh,
in the general case,
and certainly in the case of big lies,
virtually all the time,
the liar knows he's lying and is hoping not to get caught and is picking his
words carefully so as not to get caught and keeping track of the things he said.
Uh,
and,
and is consciously calculating against the expectations of cogency and,
uh,
um,
plausibility in his audience.
I mean,
there's a massive calculation going on virtually all of which is conscious in a
liar.
And it seems to me that that is,
it's going to be detectable in with great,
reliable,
the,
at some point it just seems like it's inevitable.
What everything progress's everything gets better.
And that's something they're working on a,
on a constant basis,
whether it's a hundred years from now or 200 years from now,
what people will,
they'll hate this.
The Orwellian,
uh,
fears of the,
of the misuse of this or the fears about the war or William misuse of this are
pretty easy to,
to,
um,
uh,
get ahold of.
And,
and I think,
um,
people feel like there's that kind of the last and most,
uh,
critical,
loss of cognitive liberty,
I may say.
So if,
if you,
if you didn't have the fundamental right to privacy that could be safeguarded by
lies,
uh,
something crucial to our humanity has been lost.
I think many people will feel that.
And it would,
won't matter how high you pile the benefits.
I mean,
you talk about the guy who was in prison for and,
and killed and he didn't kill his daughters,
but we thought he did and we killed him.
And you multiply that guy by 100,000.
Uh,
and you talk about,
you know,
treaties and deceptions at the level of nation states where millions of lives
hang in the balance.
Um,
there are people who are going to say,
no,
this is not acceptable.
And,
and I,
I think,
um,
and they'll,
they'll have a few points on their side,
but I think the,
the,
the cost to us personally and economically and socially for consequential lives,
um,
I'm not,
I'm not imagining a world where we would have lie detection technology running
all the time so that every time you,
you know,
someone says,
how are you?
And you say I'm fine but you're actually not fine.
And then some,
a red light's going to go off on your sweater,
Turkey test.
Yeah.
I mean there's nothing,
there's not,
um,
I don't think any of us would want to live in that world.
But when the stakes are high and conversations matter,
and even just in court say,
you know,
the conversation is,
is important enough and a consequential enough that it has now moved into a
court and we've got lawyers on both sides and now we've got people swearing o's
of honesty.
Let's have this conversation under,
in a,
in a framework where we know that lies will be detected.
I think,
I think any sane person is going to sign up for that.
He says on the pro,
the,
the progression though,
that's always existed.
Like people were resisting books,
you know,
when books were first printed.
Yeah.
Cause it was going to erode our,
our memory,
which it probably did,
but uh,
yeah,
they,
they thought that was something crucial to our happiness would be lost by,
by,
uh,
by literacy.
Well,
there's a lot of people that also believe going online.
It's bad.
I've talked to lot of people that take pride
in not going online.
I think it's hilarious and it's like,
dude,
do you know,
you're just the guy that doesn't like books.
You're the same guy and the guy,
you're the guy who doesn't want a cell phone.
If you don't want them people to know where you are and you want to be free,
those days are gone,
man.
Those days are gone.
There's a new world going on.
By the way,
if you're driving around your car,
everybody knows who you are.
They can find you.
It's super easy.
You know,
you have a gps in there.
It's very unique.
Like try,
it's,
if they lived,
the police need to find you.
They trace it,
they find you instantly.
So I like you.
You're not hiding like there's no hiding anymore.
Yeah.
Although it's interesting.
I don't know it clearly there are some form of progress that is um,
harmful and you could be only dimly aware or just sheerly oblivious to the harms
a until after it's too late.
And I,
I,
I'm not sure how,
I mean just speaking personally,
my own use of,
of the Internet and my use of the way in which my,
my day gets segmented by the checking of email and,
and just,
uh,
it just,
the way I can disappear online in the middle of a conversation,
you have to,
I think we all have to be mindful of what that,
what that's doing to us and very good point.
And it's,
um,
I mean,
just to be on the phone with someone and also be checking your email.
that's something that,
that you can in a very lazy way,
just do more times than not.
And it's,
it's a,
um,
it's,
uh,
they're now a thousand moments like that,
that we all confront.
And if we're not,
if we're not aware of,
of how it's playing with,
um,
the fabric of our lives,
that you just,
you can just wake up one day with a very fragmented kind of attention and,
um,
uh,
it's just a,
um,
it's just,
uh,
it's,
it's a less satisfying,
there's something about multitasking that is,
I think,
intrinsically stressful and not rewarding,
but you know what the real issue is?
It's not really multitasking.
Yeah.
No.
You're sitting there and someone's checking their phone.
They're not really talking,
you know,
you're just,
you're just segmenting your,
the experience.
I was at a dinner the other day and there was four dudes and they were all on
their phone.
I was like,
this is the craziest shit ever.
Like no one's talking to anybody.
We're all just looking at our phones.
Like,
this has bananas.
let's make an agreement.
Shut these bitches off.
Or an hour.
Wow.
My kids,
you know,
I don't want it.
Then what if someone calls,
you know,
work is in the middle of the deal.
Nobody wants to just d two,
and,
you know,
vacation,
we'll do what I'm vacation.
She,
I didn't check my email for five days.
It was like a big deal.
You disconnected from the fucking hive.
You're crazy.
What do you make of this whole NSA privacy thing?
Do you think that can be rectified?
It seems like when the genie's out of the bottle with something like that,
like once they can do that and then once they justify doing that,
like,
you know,
and not all that Obama has been lying about it,
like left and right.
It's fascinating when you find out that he oversaw a lot of these,
these decisions to,
to,
to spy on people
and there's a lot of things that were done during the Bush administration before
him.
Uh,
would that go way back to 2002?
Yeah.
German counselor,
Counselor Confronts Obama about us spying on her cell phone.
Why didn't you spy and the German chancellor,
do you think she's a terrorist?
Is she evil when they're like that?
I mean that we have this history of espionage,
which in which that is just clearly something you would do.
That one
problem here is just that.
And this is one of the consequences of,
of um,
increasing transparency,
uh,
when,
when one,
certain facts or acknowledged people have to respond to them.
There's,
there's a,
you know,
I know,
and you know that I know that,
you know,
and now this is now this what was a,
essentially an open secret has to be explicitly talked about and reacted to.
And so everyone knew for,
for decades that we would make every effort we could to spy on everyone we cared
about spying on.
And that is as allies and enemies.
And everyone did it insofar as their resources allow.
And that is just what has always happened.
But the moment you actually put too fine a point on it and,
and declare the Angela Merkel's cell phone has,
has been bugged by the,
the NSA or the CIA,
um,
that is,
uh,
intolerable.
And it's just,
it's not a,
it's,
it's a little bit like,
um,
what would happen to us a,
if we saw a photo of everyone we killed in war,
you know,
if,
if it was just all transparent,
what kind of war is,
would we actually emotionally tolerate?
It might,
this might be a good thing.
It might be a bad thing.
It might be.
We might be defenseless because we would find the,
the,
the act of waging war so unconscionable that we wouldn't do it or we'd be slow
enough to do it,
that we would be,
you know,
sitting ducks.
And so,
um,
I dunno,
I mean,
I just have,
this is just a big question mark there.
How much,
Eh,
there are cases in which true information is,
prevents you from being able to do something that you actually would want to do
or,
and,
and perhaps should want to do to protect people who need to be protected,
uh,
protect people from the realities of the world that they're not necessarily
aware of,
that they haven't come to grips with like that.
Some people aren't looking for your best interest.
Some people will shoot a 15 year old girl on a bus because she wants to read
that these people are real people and you're not going to change them.
You're not going to enlighten them instantaneously in less.
You know,
that's the next invention.
And until then,
you,
you're going to have to deal with the realities of the world you live in.
Yeah.
It was so,
so either we should
have espionage or we shouldn't.
Now there's a lot of people think there shouldn't be a CIA,
there shouldn't be an NSA.
There's something,
couldn't JFK.
Um,
yeah.
So it's just if you're one of those people,
if you think we shouldn't be spying on anyone,
then obviously anything we do in that sphere is,
is unethical and,
um,
uh,
problematic.
But I'm not one of those people.
It's obvious that,
that we want information that people don't want to give us.
And that's,
and this is information that relates to,
to the most consequential things that could possibly happen.
Nuclear,
terrorism.
I mean,
we want to know if someone is trying to get loose nukes in the former Soviet
Union and blow up an American city,
they're not going to tell us.
And if there's any way to find out,
so as to interdict that process,
um,
uh,
that's,
let's call that espionage.
And that's going to be a matter of tapping people's phones or watching their
email or,
and,
and so,
and if you just have to imagine how you would feel if
a new goes off in the,
in the port of Los Angeles killing 150,000 people and making a region of Los
Angeles uninhabitable for,
for decades,
uh,
if not more.
Um,
how would you feel if the NSA said,
yet,
you know,
we actually,
we had the technology to detect all of those machinations that led to that
catastrophe,
but we decided not to use it.
We decided not to use it because Glenn Greenwald made enough noise that it was
just became politically inconvenient for us to use it.
Or we were respecting the rights of people to,
you know,
to have private evil thoughts that we weren't good.
We just didn't,
we,
it was something unsavory about reading email.
We didn't want to tap anyone's cell phone.
I think we would clearly the price is the price for that kind of delicacy is too
high in the aftermath of that kind of event.
So if you live,
if you live in a world where you think that,
uh,
or,
or if you think we live in a world where those events are,
are not only possible,
but there are people waking up tomorrow morning trying to do that.
Um,
then I,
I think you want some level of,
of,
of very energetic eavesdropping on certain people.
And,
and then,
then the question is just where do you draw the line?
And you get like a TSA pre exemption,
like one of those things,
but now you can do TSA pre,
they know you're not a terrorist,
right?
Oh,
you're Sam Harris,
the writer.
You can just go right through it.
But the only way or you're exempt is,
is to invite that intrusion into your life and the first place.
It's true.
Yeah.
So you have to be willing to,
to part with some kind of private isn't mean to be the devil's advocate position
would,
would be that there's a reason why these people were upset at us.
We're occupying Holy Land,
we're doing terrible things,
were stealing the resources.
There's a lot of things that the United States is doing that actually promotes
this radical jihad.
Well,
to some degree that's true.
Most of that is based on their religious perception of the world and the first
place.
So that,
I mean there's so many of these grievances are,
are w w liberals tend to describe them as political,
but,
but they're actually religious grievances.
So you know,
if the,
if the Saudis invite us in to help secure the oil wells,
that Saddam Hussein is threatening,
right?
Someone like Osama bin Ladin perceives that as the sacrilege of having an
infertile boots on the ground in the Holy Land,
right.
That end.
And then someone like Glenn Greenwald,
we'll describe that as a political grievance.
That's a religious grievance.
That is,
that is,
we were invited in by a government in that case to protect oil wells.
Uh,
we're not stealing the oil.
We're buying the oil.
And I mean this is a bit disingenuous because Saddam wasn't really a religious
guy.
Oh no,
he,
no,
he's,
he was not religious,
but he was using and he won.
He was tamping down the,
the religious sectarianism of the Iraqi people,
which,
you know,
with a moment we removed him,
can chaos exploded.
Um,
but so,
so hoop,
but what,
who gets the blame for all of that?
It's like,
wait,
we've got Sunni and Shia killing each other based on,
is that politics,
we can call it politics,
but that,
that is religious sectarianism,
no questions.
And in that way it can actually be argued that it was better for the people that
have that ruthless dictator in power than it is to have the United States sort
of loosely helping them govern themselves.
I don't agree with that obviously.
Um,
I think,
you know,
ultimately the best thing for everybody would be some sort of a compromise.
But when you look at the fact that these people are both Muslims,
they just have a different sect of Muslim,
of Islam and they,
they kill each other like on a regular basis.
Like the amount of slaughter involved in.
Most people don't even know that that's going on.
We're not,
we're not paying attention to it.
It's,
it,
it shows up on your page eight of the New York Times sometimes.
But you know,
sometimes,
but,
but the,
the um,
I mean this is,
that's one thing you have to keep in mind whenever you hear,
uh,
people rail against us,
foreign policy being the engine is driving this global jihad and Muslim
violence.
You just have to look at what Muslims are doing to other Muslims in context that
have absolutely nothing to do with our overreaching are colonialism are stealing
of resources.
You can,
you can make us as bad as you want,
but go to Pakistan and ask yourself,
why are they,
why are Sunni's billowing up?
She a or a mosques,
eh,
but some guy is willing to lay down his life tomorrow morning and you know,
become a bomb and kill 75 people.
Um,
and it's got nothing to do with us.
It's got that is,
and it's,
we can,
we call it politics.
It's,
we're talking about in many cases,
the victimization of a religious minority that has no political power.
It's not,
it's not politics by,
it's not like this,
these,
it's not the tea party.
You know,
really trying to get something.
This is,
this is,
uh,
this is someone waking up,
willing to die for the pleasure of killing men,
women and children.
Um,
uh,
and it's to no end apart from the imagined end that he's going to wind up in
paradise and get everyone he loves in there after they die.
Do you think that it's possible to turn that around?
Is there a way or do you think that the reason why you support the United States
occupying these countries is because they're so chaotic that you need to keep an
eye on them?
You need to keep the area settled,
but I actually don't,
I don't support,
uh,
occupation anywhere.
Actually.
I,
I never,
I supported are going into Afghanistan because we had to do it.
We had to had to strike a blow against al Qaeda.
And did we have to yeah,
no,
we had to.
What is the main,
well,
because what we look at the consequences of our never having done it before
that,
I mean,
we were,
there was this slow bleed of,
of,
of attacks on us without any real reprisal for decades.
I mean,
so,
you know,
since the early eighties,
um,
and,
uh,
we were,
you know,
the hostages in Lebanon and there were,
there were,
you know,
uh,
the marine barracks got got blown up and,
and the,
the,
the lesson drawn among the jihadis of the world was,
this is,
you know,
the West is a paper tiger,
America's a paper tiger.
They're just going to run away and we can keep taking it to them.
And um,
that is a,
um,
that's not the lesson we want jihadis to draw.
Uh,
I,
I think the lesson we want them to draw is that it is very dangerous to be a
jihadist.
And you know,
if you,
if you are desperate to get to paradise and you're going to tell all your
friends and neighbors in your,
in your suicide video that,
um,
you want to get to paradise,
uh,
we'll help you get to paradise.
I mean,
I think we have to have a policy towards,
towards the hottest,
uh,
which is a policy of,
of,
of hot war.
But I don't think we should be occupied countries to do this.
I think,
I think it should be largely covert.
Well then how are we going to control the heroin?
How do I control the heroin?
Then?
What do you mean don't occupy?
How are we going to be able to could've locked down and all that Afghany sweet
heroin.
Uh,
I thought,
well,
we can just,
we can just buy it if we want it.
It's for sale that's going on.
Did you think that uh,
the United States,
like some secret factions in the United States have some sort of a and an
involvement in profiteering off of a drug use?
I have no idea.
I mean,
I've,
you seen it,
I'm sorry to interrupt.
Yeah,
no,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's totally,
it's possible.
I've,
it's not something I've thought about.
It just,
it seems like most things are for sale.
I mean,
certainly heroin is for sale if it's not,
and it's like,
what is the margin of,
of,
you know,
for stealing it and fighting a war to steal at me?
Clearly,
whatever.
If we had ulterior profit seeking motives in any of these wars,
uh,
they didn't turn out.
They didn't out.
I mean these wars are so much more costly than anything else we could have
gotten from them.
Um,
but the,
uh,
I think the
lesson I draw from these wars is that we,
there is a consequence to having boots on the ground.
Uh,
and it's,
uh,
it's a bad one.
A,
which is,
there's this perception that we,
based on our own desire for conflict and conquest are at war with the Muslim
world.
There's a perception,
there's a perception in the Muslim world,
some of it is,
is,
is fraudulent.
And they don't really believe that some of it is,
is genuinely believed by many,
many millions of people that the west is just trying to conquer the Muslim world
and destroy this,
this,
the one true religion.
Uh,
that's not a perception that we can just keep humming for a century.
We have to deflate that.
And so,
and,
and one way to deflate it is to treat this all like a,
um,
and sometimes like a,
like a crime problem.
Uh,
but a crime problem that is going to be
remedied with covert
covert acts of violence.
So,
you know,
I think,
I think we should assassinate jihadist that's,
and,
and we shouldn't,
we shouldn't make a big thing about doing this.
We shouldn't own it.
Every time it happens,
it just should become clear in a hundred countries that if you're a jihadist who
opens open sets up shop as,
you know,
the jihad is now going to install the,
the global caliphate and kill infidels.
Um,
your life just got very dangerous.
and,
but the,
the end game for us and for,
for a global,
uh,
civil civilization is to get moderate Muslims to do that job.
I mean,
say the moderate Muslims have to realize that they need to win a civil war with
their jihadists as long as moderate Muslims and,
and conservative Muslims who are not jihadis think that jihadism is not their
problem or,
or has no or,
or they're just scared of,
of their own extremists.
Um,
there's going to be no one else to,
to,
to prosecute this war.
And there's something intrinsically inflammatory about us doing this job.
Not only in the minds of geodes,
but in the minds of,
of,
uh,
normal Muslims.
Who would never think of waging jihad,
but they just find it,
uh,
intolerable to see western,
to get,
you know,
guys sitting in,
in office parks in Vegas,
flying drones over Pakistan,
which are pretty precise and their kill a lot of bad people,
but they also kill some,
some innocent bystanders.
That is,
you don't have to be a,
someone who was going to be a jihadist to find that objectionable.
If you are a devout Muslim who just feels you're a person with conscious.
No,
but,
but there's this,
there's a salt religious solidarity that is working against us,
um,
which the only remedy for which I think is to have
moderate Muslims wherever they can be found to rise up and own this thing,
which I mean,
uh,
until until moderate Muslims find I'll Qaeda and the Taliban every bit is
inimicable inimical to their,
you know,
their hopes for this world as we do.
Um,
you know,
it's going to,
it's an untenable situation.
We can't keep doing this.
I want to go back to what you said about the war being so expensive in the first
place,
that it wouldn't be a war for selling drugs for profit.
I'm not saying that it's entirely for involved or it's based on selling drugs
for profit,
but there's no denying that the heroin production has increased radical since
NATO.
Op,
excuse me,
I have a cold ladies and gentlemen.
No,
if you could tell NATO occupation,
I mean there's an article here,
it says it's a 40 times higher production of heroin since NATO are occupied.
But all part of that could be,
again,
this is not something I know anything about,
but the,
the,
um,
there are other,
clearly there are other explanations for that.
One is just that you,
you have people
who have no other livelihood but to grow crops and the most valuable crop they
can grow is heroin.
That's true.
And that's so,
so what are they going to do?
It's like they're,
they're just coming out of the civil war obviously isn't over,
but they came out of a period of,
of,
of just wall to wall violence.
Uh,
and we just,
we,
we'd dump billions and billions of dollars in there.
We,
we,
we pave a few roads and now,
you know,
if you're an Afghan Afghany farmer,
what are you going to grow?
Um,
I,
you know,
it seems like it,
that would be the right,
the right choice if you're,
if you're someone we would get the buyer is on our side.
That's the problem.
Right?
But isn't it also the problem when they have United States army troops guarding
poppy fields?
There's video of it.
Geraldo Rivera interviewing.
I mean it's clearly that there's some military involvement.
The United States military involved in the,
the heroin production in Afghanistan.
It's like,
it's pretty transparent.
And the idea is that they're saying that the reason why they do it is because
they need to do to help these people grow their crops so that they'll ride on
the Taliban.
Yeah.
Well,
which is a perfectly reasonable explanation for me.
It says,
so you just tell me that there,
there are marines,
Guardian,
a poppy field.
There are many interpretations of that,
but one is just what you gave.
They have to win hearts and minds.
They have to figure out some way to get the non radicalized people to rat out
the very scary radicalized people who make come to kill them.
Um,
uh,
and how are we going to the item number one in,
in engineering that cooperation can't be let's force all of these people to
destroy the most profitable crop.
They,
they,
they could grow.
Um,
because of our drug laws.
That's interesting way of looking
at it.
The unfortunate thing for me though is that there's a ton of evidence that the
United States government has been involved in drug smuggling.
There was a CIA jet that had been to Guantanamo Bay twice.
It crashed with several tons of cocaine and Mexico pull that up.
It's kind of hilarious.
It's a,
he see this jet and inside of it it's just stacked with cocaine.
I think obviously this is probably not the entire organization,
but there's some factions that are profiting off of it.
They have forever.
There's a guy named Barry seal who was involved in back during the Pablo Escobar
days.
He was,
according to him,
he was selling drugs for the CIA.
There's also what happened with a freeway,
Ricky and the whole Oliver North contras in Nicaragua situation,
the United States was clearly involved in drug trafficking,
trafficking to promote uh,
a hidden war.
This is the plane crashed with several tons of cocaine.
Cocaine.
That's hilarious.
And it's a,
that's a jet that had been to Guantanamo Bay twice.
I mean I don't want to go too far down the conspiracy theory,
a rabbit hole with you,
but you have to take that into consideration that there's a lot of evidence that
some fuckery is a foot and has been for a long time.
Whether it was in Southeast Asia,
heroin in the Vietnam war or whether it's this right now there's something,
and when you say that it costs so much money anyway,
but to who it doesn't cost so much money to Halliburton,
it doesn't cost so much money until these come companies that are profiting off
of war.
The,
that's the idea is that war is,
is very profitable for the people who get the government contracts and go over
there and,
and build airplane hangars and all these different things that they're doing
over there.
It's not,
we're not talking about what's profitable or not profitable,
profitable for the United States taxpayer.
We're talking about the people that are actually controlling the game in the
first place.
Yeah.
With that.
But that's the,
that's the issue.
They is there someone controlling the game and are their interests aligned
enough so that they really have control over it.
So,
and that I think is in most cases,
I'm not saying that people never conspire or that it's not possible to have a
sufficient number of,
of people in power who,
who have selfish and shortsighted interest that can get them to do terrible
things in the world stage.
And that clearly could happen,
at least in principle.
But for the most part,
there's just,
people's interests are not aligned all that well.
There's not,
Halliburton is not that powerful so that it could decide to launch a war.
And so,
and,
and w I mean,
one way you can see this one thing I would get you to,
to reflect on is it takes someone like,
like,
um,
President Obama when he was Senator Obama,
he was against the Iraq war.
He was allegedly,
yeah,
but he spoke on this and he's a critic.
You certainly ratings nothing if you,
if you base it on what he's told us since he's got an office and what turns up
until true.
Yeah.
But I'm asking,
I'm asking how you account for that transformation in him.
So he's,
he's someone who was a critic of the former.
If
you had,
before he was elected,
if you had asked him,
what do you think about Bush and what do you think about Chanie and what you
think about Rumsfeld and what all the stuff they did,
war profiteers,
he would,
he would have a,
uh,
and,
and it's all of this came,
I'm not just speculating,
he said many of these things,
but he had a,
a very clear critique based on,
on liberal principles that,
that almost any liberal who was,
was enthusiastic about his election would recognize that this was the Iraq war
was unnecessary.
We were,
we went in there on false pretenses.
This was a terrible idea.
The consequences,
the Ma,
you know,
now there's a mess that has to be cleaned up.
But now he's become a,
to the eyes of many liberals,
just a neo-con shill,
someone who's,
who's,
you know,
more secretive and more agile and his prosecution of a covert war than Bush and
Cheney ever wore.
Um,
and what,
so what do you,
how do you explain that transformation?
Is He someone who,
uh,
was always that way and was just line,
but,
but line for some reason that doesn't make much political sense.
Um,
or was he,
uh,
is,
is there some nefarious process where some star chamber where the really the
people who are really empowered got to him and scared him.
And like he's,
he's pressing the United States,
but he had a meeting with Halliburton and a bunch of powerful guys,
some billionaires,
uh,
who,
who scared him straight and now he's just doing their bidding or don't believe
that's possible.
Yeah,
I have no,
I don't think,
I think that's,
no,
I don't think that's possible.
But,
uh,
or,
and this is the,
the,
um,
uh,
obviously the interpretation I favor or are the facts of the world so scary and
is governance so messy and is it so fucking hard to get anything done that this,
this process of apparent transformation just happens?
You know,
so,
so he gets,
so he got an office,
he's a senator who's not really privy to all the facts.
Now he's president who every morning wakes up and is told the scariest
intelligence we've got.
Um,
what does that do to you and how,
how eager does that make you to,
uh,
make sure that a,
a terrorist incident of an order of magnitude larger than September 11th,
it doesn't happen on your watch?
I mean,
imagine having the responsibility to protect whole cities from massive acts of
terror.
Just how,
just how,
how squeamish are you going to be about bugging people cell phones?
Um,
I think it's,
it's very easy to see that through no evil hand behind the scenes.
You could have somebody like Obama who was a genuine liberal,
you know,
I mean,
he's not,
he's not as far left as,
as many people want them to be,
but there's no reason to doubt that he objected to the Iraq war and,
and,
uh,
he is basically,
um,
uh,
a straight down the middle of the fairway liberal who's now essentially
functioning like a neo con,
I think.
I think the details have to be terrifying and I think it's,
I think it's just,
uh,
it's an immense responsibility.
I don't think it's either or.
I think a
possible,
excuse me.
It's very possible that both things are going on.
It's very possible that there are people that are absolutely profiting and want
to get involved in wars for profit.
And I think also the world is scary and I think it's easy to cut.
No,
but I don't think a guy like Obama,
I don't doubt that Halliburton sees an upside to a war because they make all
this stuff and they provide the services.
So yeah,
it's part of the next war is,
is part of their business plan.
But the question is how much power does any one person have for every
billionaire?
Like the head of the Koch brothers who Hoosiers twirling his mustache and uh,
doing the nefarious right wing thing.
There are billionaires who do not align with,
with them politically who can do the left wing thing.
Right.
But that's just a,
that's a microcosm of human beings in general.
There's evil people and there's nice people.
That's just that,
that doesn't necessarily preclude the idea that someone,
not just profits off war but engineer's war for profit it seems.
If you're talking about something like billions and billions of dollars and you
can justify to yourself this inevitable anyway because these people are cave
people,
they're going to fuck up and you got all these,
look what they do to women and look what they do to their,
their people.
Look they do to each other.
Look what they do to fellow Muslims.
You're all,
you're also maybe not making the best humanitarian choices because you're making
choices based on profit and the profit is absolutely enormous.
I mean it's,
it's massive and there's pretty clear evidence that the United States basically
lied to get into the Iraq war.
I mean,
I know that there was a lot of people that genuinely believe that there was
something going on in Iraq and genuinely believed that Saddam Hussein was a
threat.
But there's also people that believe it was a whole lot of fuckery,
including Poland.
Colin Powell,
well,
everyone believed when,
when Colin Powell deliver that,
that presentation at the UN,
virtually everyone bill with,
with a few exceptions,
virtually everyone believed that that was true.
No,
it was,
it was not.
It was uncontroversial that the,
the,
the premise that,
that Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass destruction was uncontroversial and all
the people who were against are going in there were against it for reasons that
did not entail doubting whether there were weapons of mass destruction.
They,
there were other reasons not to go in there.
It's just,
it was kind of a,
it was a hornet's nest.
It was to,
it was a quagmire.
It was,
it was,
you know,
what specifically are the weapons of mass destruction and that would motivate us
going there and not going into North Korea.
Oh,
right.
So it's,
well,
because of the ams,
no money in North Korea.
Well know there's that,
but no,
because he didn't,
he didn't have nukes.
He was trying to get news or we thought he was trying to get news.
I mean,
so we could deal with a chemical weapons attack and he'd give everyone a gas
mask and a hazmat suit and we can still a war.
Uh,
the,
the nukes changed the game.
And that's why,
that's one reason why Pakistan is so terrifying.
So you don't open yourself up to the possibility of conspiracy?
No,
I do.
I just know that,
that this is an adage,
I don't know where it comes from,
but never ascribed a conspiracy.
What can be explained by incompetence or the tragedy of wasted opportunity.
The idea that just because a tragedy gets capitalized on doesn't mean that the
people who capitalize on it cause the tragedy,
but that's a standard operational procedure for warriors to,
to find something wrong and say,
look,
this is what happened.
We got attacked.
We're going into Iraq.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
I see in every conspiracy,
and again,
I'm not doubting whether anyone ever conspires.
I,
it's just that there are so many constraints on people doing what they want,
especially when they're nefarious things.
Um,
the constraints largely being everyone else's opposing wants,
um,
that,
uh,
it's,
it's hard for people to,
uh,
bring these,
these big plans off.
But isn't that your argument for eavesdropping on people in the first place that
they're planning big plans?
Somebody said this,
I forget who it was.
I think somebody said it,
but it's a different scale of conspiracy.
I mean it's so,
you look at the 19 hijackers,
it's just 19 guys with box cutters and somebody.
It's a big organization.
I mean that's not just 19 guys.
Those guys planned it out.
They had help.
They learned how to fly.
They pulled it off.
Someone said,
this is not launching a war.
It's not,
it's not,
you know,
half a million guys and tank.
Right,
because it's 19 guys and not Haliburton,
not a multibillion dollar operation that the CEO,
the former CEO just happens to be the vice president of the United States and
gets multibillion dollar,
no bid contracts to go and rebuild shit.
We blow up.
I mean it's,
it's pretty connect the dots if you want it to argue for a war for profit.
That's about as cut and dry as it ever gets.
Someone said on the podcast,
I forgot who it was,
I don't know who it was.
Maybe I read it online.
Someone said,
do you believe in nine 11 we ask people if they believe in conspiracies,
do you believe in nine 11 and I'm like,
what?
What do you mean?
Does d believe nine 11 was done as experienced by the government?
No.
Do you believe it happened?
And everyone says yes.
Well then you believe in conspiracies cause there was a conspiracy.
Someone conspired to fly planes into buildings and whether or not the United
States government was involved or whether or not it was these 19 guys from Saudi
Arabia that was,
they pulled that off.
Conspiracies exist.
But something like 35% of Americans believe that the u s had some hand in that
conspiracy.
Is it really that high that we let it happen and 16% think that we engineered
it.
I hate those things though,
that we demoed the buildings,
it's someone in the dead of night had to fill the twin towers with,
with thermite and that we hit,
you know,
we hit the plunger at the right moment just just after that the planes went in
or maybe they weren't even planes,
maybe there were holograms and w once you get deep into this,
the nine 11 conspiracy,
you get,
you know the CIA faking voices of all the passengers on the flights.
It's the,
the answering
machine messages of,
of the relatives of the dead passengers,
blight by CIA for voice faking technology.
And it's just,
it's just,
it's completely insane.
And,
and,
and the,
the problem with it is,
is it's totally unconstrained by any,
um,
overall explanation or plausible hypothesis about what could have happened.
What it is,
is you,
you look at every anomaly.
I mean,
any,
any event you could possibly describe,
it's going to have a million coil.
What looked like coincidences in it,
uh,
and which,
which if you,
if you tried to engineer beforehand,
would seem like the odds against them more astronomical.
But in the aftermath,
something had to happen.
So it's like the people sold stock and American Airlines that day.
Right?
So how is it that you sold your stock and American Airlines the very day of the
day before,
uh,
an Air American Airlines jet flew into a building,
right?
How did you know that is,
that's fishy,
right?
The real problem is you find out that people buy and sell those stocks every,
yeah.
So,
but so there,
there are uncountable number of things like that,
but if you're only looking for anomalies,
anomalies,
and you're,
and,
and you're not constrained by,
by any overall thesis,
uh,
you can find them in any situation.
And,
but let me just be honest about what this picture of reality actually is.
This is the,
the most diabolical plot in human history that,
that entailed thousands of conspiracists,
um,
uh,
or conspirators and,
and they,
none of them have have crack.
No one has no one woke up feeling so guilty that they had to tell their story
and to 60 minutes.
And yet this whole thing was designed to leave George Bush reading my pet goat
at the moment that it all kicked off.
It's just not,
it's like,
it's this marriage of perfectly competent,
diabolical intelligence with the most inept.
I mean,
so,
so all these people conspired perfectly.
And yet the Arra,
the Iraq war was,
was launched as ineptly as you could possibly have been.
Well,
I certainly don't believe that the United States was involved and conspiring.
Uh,
I think there's some question that may be,
some people might have known about it.
The real issue comes when you find out about actual real false flags,
actual real false flag events that the United States is engineered that they've
pulled off,
that they haven't pulled off,
that they were planning,
that they didn't go through.
The real problem is that that's a genuine ideology.
That's a genuine thought process.
The idea of what we have to make this happen.
This is what we're going to do.
We're going to blow up a ship.
We're going to blow up a jet airliner and blame it on the Cubans and the
operations Northwoods.
Right.
Well,
but that's so,
so if you wanted to run a false flag operation and get us into a war with Iraq
under false pretenses.
So we,
we've got a no fly zone over a rack for years that we've been policing RF
sixteens
you just shoot down one of our planes and then you tell the world that Iraq
though,
we told them they couldn't shoot at us,
shot down one of our planes.
This is an act of war we're going in,
that would have been totally justifiable.
What you don't do is send mostly Saudis to come kill 3000 of the most connected
people.
Uh,
yeah,
we're in agreement and destroy our economy.
We're in agreement.
I don't think that the United States engineered it.
I say before,
so I know some people do and many,
many people do.
But you know what?
46% of Americans think the earth is less than 10,000 years old.
And the problem with those poles are,
those are a hundred percent idiots that answer the polls.
Who fucking answers polls?
I don't answer a poll.
Nobody had no answers.
Polls,
people call you up randomly in the middle of the day and ask you to answer a
poll.
Most likely you're busy.
Most likely you're going to hang up the amount of people that actually have an
answer.
Polls that did.
I don't think they represent the,
the,
the real,
the real population in the United States,
right?
Well,
when you say it's 13% 14% of the people that you polled,
right?
But there are ways of correcting for that.
So if for instance,
you could just pull college students,
you know,
you could,
you could literally be in a poly sci class and ask people who got into college
and are attending climb that.
That wouldn't be,
that would be an elite sample.
Uh,
but you get weird chore.
You get weird opinions even in among elite samples.
Well,
that number,
the 46% of Americans believe the earth is less than 10,000 years old.
That's a real one.
That's a gallop Jolla.
That alone throws poles like,
oh,
13% of the United States engineered nine 11.
Okay.
That's nothing compared to the idea that the earth is 10,000 years old.
The amount of evidence that the earth is more than 10,000 years old is
staggering.
And yet a way higher percentage believe in that.
They believe.
And that's because it's a religious doctrine of course.
And,
and that has been stable,
aren't they?
Religious isn't a,
isn't a belief in the government engineered nine 11 or isn't a million different
conspiracies?
Don't they have sort of a religious aspect to them?
The,
the pure belief,
the confirmation bias,
the ignoring anything contradictory.
People want to have an answer for sure.
Definitely.
Whether it's pro or con,
there's that real thing that people want to wrap something up tight with a bow.
Either the government is full of evil criminals that are trying to kill your
baby or it's all just a part of life.
And the real issue was there's Boogie men out there.
Yeah,
yeah,
I know.
I think there is,
it hijacked some of the same features of the human mind or,
or have certain human minds because many people are very uncomfortable without
cognitive closure.
They're very not knowing why something happened is um,
d stabilizing to people to different degrees.
And um,
whereas one person can just feel no emotional cost to living with the mystery of
why something happened or freely admitting whether they have no idea.
Um,
or merely having a,
you know,
a hunch.
Other people crave certainty and,
and there are other features to it.
So people have an intuition that something huge
couldn't have been kicked off by something trivial,
you know?
So if something huge happened,
if this thing is 3000 people dead and,
and,
and the biggest buildings coming down and,
uh,
the world and chaos,
that couldn't have been just 19 guys with box cutters,
that had to be the cause,
had to be bigger.
And that,
that I think is an intuition that some people have more than others.
And it's a,
it's a faulty intuition,
but it's,
it's,
some people have a,
have certain schemas that through which they view human events,
which make conspiracy thinking,
uh,
very,
um,
attractors,
very plausible.
And Uca,
you'll notice that there's been actually research done on this,
that if you,
if you're someone who believes one conspiracy theory,
you're very likely to be someone who believes all of them.
And you're someone who's,
who's read the JFK books and you know,
who's read the,
the,
um,
uh,
you know,
the,
the Roswell incident.
I mean,
whether you're,
you're,
you're talking about extra terrestrials and,
and,
uh,
you know,
CIA,
uh,
misadventures in many places.
There's a whole esoteric literature out there that,
that I'm not so familiar with,
but I know that people who go down one rabbit hole tend to go down many of the
others.
And it's a kind of,
it's kind of a personal,
it's a personality type that,
um,
I think you can become,
you know,
I tried to,
uh,
it's actually,
it's,
it's interesting.
You,
you,
so you mentioned,
um,
why you asked me what I thought about the NSA thing and to some degree,
my,
my perception of this,
this news event has been polluted by my relationship with Glenn Greenwald,
who we don't like that guy.
No,
no.
I actually started,
it was interesting as I started out liking him,
not liking him and that I aligned with,
with all of his views or even many of his views,
but we had a,
a,
a brief,
uh,
personal,
exchange by email where he actually did me a favor,
which was,
which was great.
And it actually links up with this conspiracy thing.
Um,
so I have someone in my life who's,
who's,
who's very close to me,
who is a nine 11 conspiracy.
Very close to you.
Yeah.
Member minds,
dad or something.
A member of my family who is a,
who is a,
uh,
and a very bright guy who is a nine 11 conspiracy guy.
And so I fought with him about this for now,
for a years.
So like every six months just,
it,
it blows up and we'll,
we'll write the,
you know,
that it will have the two hour email exchange.
Um,
and I've tried to debunk this and uh,
uh,
and one idea I had about how to debunk it as,
as I,
I noticed that he had a few liberal writers who he really admired.
And Glenn Greenwald was,
was the top of the list.
And I knew that Glenn Greenwald couldn't be a nine 11 conspiracy.
So I reached out to Glenn.
I'd never met Glenn.
And I said,
I said,
will you do me a favor and just tell me in a short little essay why you don't
believe any of this stuff?
Why,
why is it that you,
I mean,
you seem to align with a lot of these concerns,
the overreach of power and,
you know,
NSA wiretapping and,
and why is it,
why someone in your position,
uh,
not at all attracted by this nine 11 truth nonsense.
Um,
and he wrote,
he wrote the perfect email.
He,
and I told him why I needed this.
I mean,
I as basically an intervention for,
for a family member.
He wrote the perfect email,
which was just crazy enough to give him perfect credibility.
I mean,
he's like,
you know,
he was like,
grateful for the nine 11 truth people.
And he was,
it was,
it was perfect email.
And I imagine that I was going to send this into my,
um,
my relatives brain and it was going to,
he was going to have the epiphany that I was expecting,
which was here's someone he trusts as an authority on all of these points.
And this is why this guy who's got much more time to look at this,
then,
uh,
my relative does,
um,
this is why he won't touch it with a 10 foot pole.
And it had,
it did not have that effect at all.
All he wanted to do was to get in touch with Glenn Greenwald,
show him all them,
get to educate them,
show them all this stuff that he hadn't seen it.
Right.
So anyway,
but I started in this place with Glen,
um,
uh,
feeling very positive toward him.
And then he,
he just basically in a,
in a,
in a very unethical way,
misrepresented my views in a series of articles.
And when I called him on a privately,
he just doubled down.
He basically just said,
fuck you.
This is what I,
you,
even if you don't think this is what you were saying,
this is what I think you were saying.
Oh Wow.
And um,
what,
what was his argument?
What w what was his point like?
What was he trying to paint?
Well,
it was this whole Islamophobia business.
He basically branded me a racist who,
who hates Muslims.
And there's a,
there's an animus against us against people.
I'm not talking about ideas.
I'm,
this is,
this is just by you asking him to write something.
No,
no,
this is,
this was unrelated,
but this is why I,
this is why the NSA thing,
this is why the NSA thing was sort of hit me in the,
in,
in the,
uh,
the wrong part of my brain because when,
when Glenn was the,
was the quarterback for the,
for the Snowden revelations,
um,
basically I saw a guy who's just blogging and his underpants in Brazil with his
10 dogs and his boyfriend who was handed this story,
which is in fact true.
I mean,
if he's not this great investigative journalist who found this,
he was based on his ideological bias and his track record with someone who
Snowden liked and thought would be,
you know,
very sympathetic year for this story.
And he just handed him the story.
I mean,
you,
so tomorrow night's,
someone could email you the next big decades shaking story,
right?
Based on your interests and how they align with his and you,
that wouldn't make you the greatest investigative journalist.
So anyway,
so Greenwald was someone who really was not functioning like a journalist,
and he certainly does not have the principles of honesty and fact checking.
And admitting when he was wrong,
got something wrong that,
that most journalists have drummed into them.
So I,
I,
I find him a very unreliable witness because I've spoken to him in person.
Why we have a long exchange email,
just email.
I fucking hate email.
I mean,
I love it,
but I hate it.
Clarifying something
as important as this.
Yeah,
no,
it's true.
But I mean in a lot,
and this is another way technology is,
is screwing us up because we're,
we're,
we are able to,
things run off the rails when you're riding in a way that they wouldn't face to
face.
Yeah.
Like a blog about someone you could write some horrible things.
Whereas if you were sitting in front of that person talking to them and you
said,
they'd be like,
well,
I don't think that,
no,
you've misinterpreted my position.
I think this and add respect to Europe.
And then you could have a nice exchange and said,
someone just can just spew out their nonsense and a blog with no one checking
them and then,
you know,
it gets really,
it gets really squirrely when you're allowed to do that.
Unchecked with no social cues and that's what he did and he,
but he makes it,
he considered a virtue.
He,
I mean he said this
in the New York times when he was just becoming famous for the Snowden story.
He,
they asked him about his approach to journalism and he said,
he said that he approaches it as a litigator.
He's,
he assumes people are aligned and then he goes and checks to Joe.
It goes and tries to prove that they're lying and so and so and may
interpersonally.
This is a highly dysfunctional and obnoxious way to be.
And so when I'm representing my ideas,
he's assuming I'm lying and he goes to,
it goes to try to prove that I'm lying and then he quote minds or he gets
readers to quote mine my work where he can pull sentences out of context which
seem out of context.
I can see how someone would see it as an inflammatory thing to say about Islam.
But I mean I have not been,
it's impossible to catch me saying something extreme about Islam that I didn't
mean to say.
Everything I've ever said about Islam is,
is it was incredibly well thought out.
I know exactly what I think.
And it has absolutely no logical relationship to racism because I,
cause I'm,
everything I say is it applies every bit as much to Gino John Walker Lindh or
Adam Gadahn or any white guy who woke up in Marin or,
or Orange County and decided to join the Jihad.
In fact,
it applies even more to them because they weren't indoctrinated from birth by
any,
by any kind of Middle Eastern cultural upbringing.
Um,
and so,
uh,
so,
so the,
the eye view Greenwald as just the,
um,
the least scrupulous and among the most consequential,
uh,
people who have been flogging this Islamophobia thing and it's,
it's,
um,
and it's been very ugly.
And so in so far as the NSA story has been his story,
I,
it's been,
I've had,
I've had to do a lot of kind of,
uh,
parsing of what,
what,
what is it,
what said because his,
his intuitions about what is important and factual.
I,
I just fundamentally don't trust so it doesn't have his philosophy on and just
how he operates.
But that's not to say that the Edward Snowden story isn't a huge story.
It's absolutely huge.
How do you win?
I think it is too.
So for you it's just a very bitter sweet thing because you don't like that guy
personally.
But also I'm uncertain about where the line is between fax.
We genuinely want to know and,
and a public service rendered by journalists and whistle blowers who leak those
facts and treason that is really consequential that we should have laws against
and prosecute people for.
And I don't know where Snowden falls on that continuum.
I just,
I'm just agnostic as to what,
um,
uh,
I mean I,
10 years from now,
are we going to think he was a hero or someone who did our country more harm
than anyone in the last hundred years?
I don't know the answer to that question.
I really think he's the guy who got the ball rolling.
I think that's what it is.
I think he let people know what was going on behind the scenes for quite a long
time.
And I think that's good.
No lying right.
It's what you were talking about in your book.
It's lying.
The government lies.
And we caught him on a light and now we know it's not,
it's not an ally.
Well,
it's not a lie
if the NSA,
if the job of the NSA is to spy on people,
but everybody,
well,
no,
I don't know where it,
so
the government side,
I mean,
no question Obama lied about was large.
It was going on.
Yeah.
There's this larger question about what,
what do you want the NSA to do,
right?
What do you want our intelligence or organizations to do?
Um,
that is,
I don't feel like I'm a,
I mean if given a menu of things to check off you,
you and I may check off check different boxes and what we want them to do.
And frankly,
I don't know,
uh,
where I draw the line on some of these questions because it's,
you know,
I,
I'm just a conversation away from someone who has more information than me about
top secret information,
um,
from being convinced that,
oh yeah,
we really do want that information.
Yeah.
I don't want my daughter to grow up in a world where nukes are going off in our
cities.
So yeah,
if you're telling me that,
that tapping that phone or reading,
reading all email,
if only retrospectively,
um,
is a way to stop that.
And here's why.
Here's why you think that,
um,
I could be sold on all of these points.
I mean,
there's nothing about,
there's nothing about my email that I feel like needs to be private.
If you keep raising the stakes on the side of arguing why it shouldn't be
private.
But isn't the argument always that the United States has shown a long history of
deception?
I mean,
how do you,
like when you put this into your box,
what do,
what do you put false flags?
Where do you put though?
Yeah,
well,
no,
the,
I mean that,
that's the,
so the consequence of having a government that lies on issues like that over and
over and over and over again since the beginning of time.
I know it's,
it's the most toxic thing and yeah,
but you're giving them opportunity to have,
this is not bad power,
but this is,
but so I talk about this briefly in my book about espionage being something that
if you grant that undercover operations are sometimes necessary,
then you,
what you're saying is there is some space in which otherwise good and ethical
people are going to need to lie now with,
so the way I,
I think about that is,
I think that is necessary.
I think it is,
it is.
Someone is a,
it is a life that I don't want.
I couldn't be,
I couldn't work for the NSA,
but it's an unfortunate fact and the fact that,
yeah,
I couldn't,
so I couldn't be the guy who comes home to his wife and lies about what he did
all day.
Right.
Because that's part of the career.
Um,
I don't want to be that person.
I,
I view it as a kind of moral self-immolation where you just,
you're,
you,
you have to take a hit for the team in this spectacular way,
in order to function in that space.
And,
um,
but I think it's probably necessary.
And so,
but it's,
but within that frame,
it's not actually deceptive if the NSA,
the NSA says,
listen,
we're going to,
we're going to suck up a ton of data.
Um,
and we're going to abide by laws.
We're not going to,
we're not going to imprison you for,
uh,
growing pot based on having stuck this data up.
But we're looking for jihadists.
That's something I can sign onto.
And we may want to,
you know,
read the fine print there.
Uh,
but,
um,
I was never under the illusion that the NSA was doing anything other than that.
So it's not,
that's not a surprise to me.
I,
and I don't think it's a surprise to anyone.
And so,
and,
and keeping,
you know,
lying and keeping secrets are different things.
We,
you know,
we need people to keep secrets.
We need.
And,
and you can honestly keep a secret.
You can,
the president can say,
I can't tell you that that's top secret.
Our national security depends on my not telling you that.
Right?
That's an honest statement.
And if you know,
if you,
if I asked you how much money you have in your bank account,
you know,
tell me,
tell our listeners now you can say,
I don't want to say that's,
that's,
that's an honest statement.
When you talked earlier about your friend,
the story about the woman who lied in front of her friend immediately damaged
the relationship.
Right?
Why would you ever,
knowing that the government has planned and possibly executed false flags,
why would you ever give them the benefit of the doubt?
Well,
again,
this,
this comes to,
um,
that's,
I mean
the larger question of human nature.
So what,
like what do you think is going on in the world?
Do you think that there are it,
most people,
most of the time are psychopaths or,
or a ruthlessly mercenary and,
uh,
out to just screw everyone?
Or do you think those are the anomalies and what do you think of government?
Do you think government is so corrupting of otherwise good people that they're
just going to just,
just going to run riot with their power all the time and everywhere?
Or do you think basically it's a lot of good people inefficiently trying to get
stuff done that we need done?
And if you're on the,
I think the more realistic side of that,
of those questions,
I think,
I think you have to admit that,
that it's,
for the most part,
they're,
they're people just like us in a bureaucracy trying to get stuff done and their
influence.
I mean,
there are so many competing interests that the bad people don't have as much
power as you fear.
They have a,
and the good people don't have as much power as you want them to have.
And so,
so to,
so to conspire to just grab all the strings of the military and,
uh,
wage a war on false pretenses or,
you know,
sit,
divert our fighter jets so that these,
this hijack plane can fly into the World Trade Center.
Um,
I mean,
how many people in the,
in the air force had to conspire to decide to,
you know,
run war games elsewhere so that we wouldn't be able to respond?
I mean,
you're then you're at what you're attributing to people are conscious motives to
kill massive numbers of innocent people that I just,
I think,
um,
just could not form in the minds of most people most of the time.
Well,
if that's the case,
then how did false flags ever get planned out?
How was the Northwoods document ever signed by the Joint Chiefs of staff and
vetoed by Kennedy when they were planning on arming Cuban friendlies and bombing
Guantanamo Bay,
right?
Where they were going to have a drone.
Jetliner they're going to have a jet and blow it up and then we're going to
blame it on the Cubans.
They were going to kill Americans.
They're going to kill Americans in Guantanamo Bay.
How could that possibly fall into what you're saying?
Well,
no,
there,
there are,
I mean,
so,
so we,
but we do this all that we kill Americans all the time.
Right?
But like that,
no,
US pull the trigger in order to,
how could you possibly justify that is that's the only way to do it.
The only way to do it is to have a false flag event where we kill Americans and
lie and blaming on other people.
I mean that goes against the very doctrine of the line book that goes against
the very idea that human interaction should be at all times honest,
especially at the highest levels of government.
It should in fact be even more important.
No,
I'm not.
I'm not saying it's a,
it's a good thing and I'm saying the consequence of finding out that one such
event has occurred,
not just one.
There's been many.
No,
but the consequence of even one is this very conversation,
these very doubts in the minds of millions of people.
Wouldn't you assume when there's been several that it's probably a a method of
operating that that's how they do it.
If you find out about the Gulf of Tonkin,
you find out what Bush and Cheney we're planning on Iran before they left
office.
When you fall or allegedly,
what do I know?
You know when you,
when you find out what the Northwoods document,
what do you mean?
Where do you put all that?
That's,
that's clear.
That's people that are on our side killing our people in order to get us into a
war.
When we kill other people and profit like crazy.
It seems pretty cut and dry and I think there might be,
you mean looking at it the way you're looking at it?
I see what you're saying,
but not with all the evidence,
not what all the evidence that it's actually happened.
I see what you're saying.
If there wasn't any evidence,
if it was just nine 11 and everybody was using that as an example,
I agree with you.
I think it's probably most likely a series of coincidences and most likely we
just had lax security and most likely 19 people plan this out and pulled it off.
However,
when you look at the Gulf of Tonkin,
when you look at the Northwoods incident,
when you look at,
you look at all these different things that we have planned,
it's not one,
it's several and it's several over the course of several different
administrations.
The Bush administration,
I mean the,
the,
the Kennedy Administration,
I mean,
the,
during Kennedy's Day they were doing this,
well,
what I would say is that in the case of nine 11,
you have on the other side,
a,
a very obvious conspiracy that's taking credit for it that has taken credit for
it.
I mean,
you have this,
this phenomenon of al Qaeda and Global Jihad,
uh,
which much of which is,
there is much of this violence is directed at the rest of the Muslim world.
And it's not just us,
but you have,
we have a clear enemy that thinks it's our enemy that is taking credit for,
uh,
these,
goals that immune to call them an own goal.
When you have someone,
uh,
who's,
who's seemed to be the kicker and who's taking credit for being the kicker.
And,
um,
it just seems like a,
it's a misapplication of the principle.
Even if we were going to agree that,
that,
that we,
you know,
every few years draw our own blood for some perverse reason of trying to,
to,
to motivate ourselves to do something we wouldn't otherwise want to do.
Well,
I would assume that if there's a series of events that have taken place that
have absolutely either been planned or,
absolutely,
I mean,
the Northwoods document is pretty straight forward.
It's,
there's really no denying it.
A Gulf of Tonkin basically reported in history classes today that that was a
false flag event.
Right.
So those are,
those are real,
forget about nine 11.
Let's throw that in there.
Gulf of Tonkin.
Yeah.
In the book.
And,
and,
and they're,
you know,
many other,
um,
it more easily understood,
uh,
La big lies that should worry us.
So for instance,
I mentioned pharmaceutical companies and big pharmaceutical companies seem to
clearly rig their data.
Uh,
and this puts people in a state of chronic doubt about whether you can trust
anyone in a position of authority you got when you have people,
there's no one who knows more about whether drugs are efficacious,
then the people who are designing drugs,
right?
But doesn't that kind of disingenuous you dealing with an entirely different
group of people that you're saying are also evil?
Does it?
No,
I'm not saying it's evil.
I'm saying,
I'm saying that the,
the,
the principal that is,
well,
one,
there's two principles.
One is just a willingness to lie.
That's right.
That is the thing that enables all of us.
But there's also just,
um,
and I think this is,
this is,
um,
the most,
the most important change we could make and in our society as it is to notice
the ways in which systems of incentives,
because otherwise good people to behave like bad people.
And they're,
they're endless numbers of examples of this.
But you don't have to be a bad person to behave in evil ways.
If you're part of a system,
you know,
the,
the entire tendency of which is to inclined toward evil.
So if you are,
and if you just follow the incentives,
and so they're very simple,
kind of a petri dish.
Examples of this.
And then one example I use is if you talk about what it's like to be thrown into
a maximum security prison,
I mean,
I imagine you get sent to Folsom prison and you're an innocent person.
You're not,
you're not a violent person.
You want,
and you're,
you have this,
this nightmare experience of now you're thrown in prison for a crime he didn't
commit.
And
all you want to do is get through your,
that this experience,
you know,
your 10 years,
say,
all you want to do is do your decade of,
of,
of time in peace unmolested by all these other people.
Uh,
and you're terrified that you're going to be victimized by people.
That the reality is that you are,
you're coming into a situation where the,
the,
the incentives are so perversely misaligned that even a good person like you who
just wants to be a nice guy,
it's going to have to align himself with a psycho Rena,
racist psychopaths,
uh,
in order to not be screwed over by everyone.
I mean,
so for instance,
you'd have to so,
so in,
in most maximum security prisons,
they exist in a perpetual state of race war.
So as you know,
the whites against the blacks against the Mexicans,
they get you to and,
and uh,
certain Mexicans against other Mexicans,
but it's just like you have,
it's shattered into racial gangs and a white guy,
like you would have to join a,
a white supremacist Yang.
Now you might not have a racist,
you might not have a racist bone in your body,
but the only way for you not to be fucked over by everyone is to align yourself
with a gang,
isn't what you're saying.
Another reason not trust the government.
You're saying that the government's evil.
You're saying the gun people do evil things because they get involved with evil
psychopaths,
meaning the government?
No,
no.
Which is why I'm saying that was flags occur.
Oh No,
I'm saying that we need to be aware of,
of the way incentives can be perverse.
Where,
where,
where you,
you,
your natural selfishness and your natural fear and your natural desire just to,
just to survive can be channeled in ways that make you as an otherwise good
person,
uh,
collaborating to,
to,
to do terrible things.
And there's,
there,
there are many ways in which be so conflicts of interest are,
the classic example is you have,
you have CEOs who can run the global economy off a cliff because their
incentives are totally perverse.
They have no,
they have,
there's no economic incentive for them not to just leverage their company out of
existence if they've,
you know,
if,
if they can benefit from this,
this windfall,
you know,
pop of the stock and they have a golden parachute.
I mean there's,
so there's the,
there's the problem of moral hazard where it's like there's no,
if there's no consequence to being rapaciously selfish,
you're going to get people being re patiently selfish to the detriment of
everyone.
And so,
and so the point I'm making is that sort of two levels at which you can,
you can try to improve human life.
You can,
you can argue that each person needs to have a,
a more more refined ethical code,
you know,
you have,
you have to be more honest.
I have to be more honest.
Or uh,
you can have,
or in addition you can have systems where interests are aligned so that,
so that we match.
So that the,
the,
the penalties for the,
the rewards for honesty or more obvious.
And,
and,
and um,
I mean you'd have a system where,
where people,
I mean,
another classic example is like,
I like the job market where people,
everyone's patting their resumes because they know everyone else pads their
resumes.
So it's like you're trying to get a job.
You're desperate to get a job,
your,
that your family won't eat unless you get a job.
And you know that every one else applying for this job has padded.
His resume has lied about his background.
So everyone else does false flags.
So Obama gets an office and does exactly the same thing.
It's that we're saying no,
no,
I'm saying,
I'm saying that,
that we need,
there's two levels at which we address these problems.
And,
and w one problem you're pointing to is,
is,
um,
a system level in,
in this case,
government level,
uh,
misalign misaligned incentives that have great consequence,
which,
which don't require evil people all the time to pull the string.
You don't think they requires evil people to do a false flood over.
But in a false,
if you're saying we're going to blow up a jet and fake and pretend that another
country did it,
um,
yeah,
that would require evil people to,
to hatched the idea and say,
do it.
In all fairness,
I think there was an empty jet.
I think they're going to,
no,
no.
I'm so think of a prototypical situation where it seems,
um,
uh,
as bad as possible.
Yes.
That would require,
um,
I mean,
the reason why I don't believe the September 11th conspiracy theory is that
would,
it would require too many evil people.
It just makes no sense.
I still don't understand how you rectify the idea of false flags.
Like where do you put that?
Well,
I,
so the,
I mean,
there are many fall,
I don't know which,
which are true.
I mean,
I believe the Gulf of Tonkin Tonkin was a false flag.
And what about North Woods?
I don't know enough about it.
Okay.
What about the,
did you pay any attention to the,
the plan allegedly that Bush and Cheney were concocting to get us into Iran
before he left office?
I don't know if that's true at all.
No.
No,
but so,
so for instance,
there's a new book about the Kennedy assassination,
which,
which brings,
and I don't know if I,
I don't think the guy is a conspiracy theorist at all here,
but I think he thinks Oswald did it.
But there's a new book which showed us,
I don't,
I dunno,
I mean,
I think,
I think it's,
I think it's a very likely that the,
I mean the Warren Commission seemed,
I haven't read this book,
but,
um,
from what I know,
the Warren Commission seems to have been a ridiculously inept,
uh,
effort to get to the truth and with many,
um,
uh,
perverse obstacles to getting to the truth.
One being that,
that Warren want to inconvenience,
uh,
Jacqueline Kennedy at all.
So I mean,
she's,
she's grieving.
He didn't want to interview her.
He wouldn't let her be interviewed on the,
you know,
on the record.
He interviewed her at her himself,
I think.
And,
and it just sort of summarized what she said.
Um,
so there's just all kind of weird ways in which this thing was never about
really getting to the bottom of what happened.
But,
uh,
the,
the point is that when you look at all the way,
but like,
that is a,
that's a,
that's an all too human made that you,
you can,
you can look at it some nefarious interpretation of that.
Like,
you know,
he knew that this was a mob hit that was enabled by the CIA or whatever the
story is.
Um,
and you know,
this is his way of,
of,
uh,
you know,
hiding the truth or he's just a guy who is embarrassed to ask this,
the grieving widow who was,
who was a,
you know,
a friend of his,
a about what it was like to see her husband's face get blown off.
You know,
so it's like they're there,
there are alternate explanations for these things.
And yet the conspiracy side is always,
um,
uh,
the nefarious mustache twirling,
perfect genius of evil interpretation.
And I think that,
uh,
it rarely is true,
certainly in a society where political power is not as concentrated as it is.
And,
uh,
you know,
in the,
under the Third Reich,
I think there's probably a little bit of both in there.
I think there's definitely some inept,
uh,
qualities of the Warren Commission,
but there's also this search for a predetermined outcome.
That's why they,
the,
the whole reason why the magic bullet theory was invented was because there was
a bullet that hit a curb stone underneath the overpass.
They had account for that.
That's why they accounted for one bullet,
doing all this damage to different people instead of,
you know,
making them more obvious.
Conclusion.
There was more than one more than one shooter.
I mean,
that seems much more likely.
if one person was shooting,
why would you just assume that Lee Harvey Oswald didn't have a cohort?
Why would you just assume that?
I mean,
they want it to wrap it up nice and tidy.
The same reason why Jack Ruby got to Lee Harvey Oswald in front of all those
cops,
know security shoots him,
puts it to end,
you know,
he had all these obvious mob ties.
I mean,
it's so obvious.
It's so silly.
In fact,
to think that there wasn't something going on.
I think the truth,
like many things lie somewhere in the middle.
It's not an either or situation,
but I don't think Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone.
He might've been a part of it.
It's very possible he was a part of it,
but I don't think he acted alone.
But usually it was what's
going on.
And again,
I'm not discounting the fact that there,
there are situations in which evil people brilliantly bring off they're evil or
evil,
conspirators conspire.
But most of the time it's people rather like us afraid for their jobs,
covering their asses,
afraid of getting sued,
doing things,
which when incentives are aligned in such a way as to make it effortless for
them to do them,
create a huge mess for everybody else.
And so you want me to judge when you,
when you look at what people do because they're going to,
if they're afraid to get sued,
you know,
just look at the,
just look at all of the stupid decisions people make in our society because they
just want to,
they want to hide the problem.
It's a,
there's a,
there's a book on,
um,
on,
uh,
what it's like to become a neurosurgeon.
I called,
uh,
when the air hits your brain and it's a,
it's a pretty entertaining and somewhat heroin look at just the training of a
neurosurgeon.
And there was,
so he talks about what it was like to be a resonant neurosurgeon.
And at one point there's a scene where a resident is a,
um,
is performing his first,
uh,
prepping us for surgery,
which entails drilling into a person's skull and,
and cutting them,
you know,
uh,
a large hole and,
prepping the,
uh,
the person's,
head for this,
the,
the chief neurosurgeon to come in and perform surgery.
And what he did is he drove the drill in way too deep.
Like,
you know,
it was supposed to go,
it was just,
just supposed to do skull,
but he just went into,
you know,
pure pink oatmeal,
um,
of the person's brain.
And his only concern at that moment was not how the patient was doing.
It was to hide the evidence that he had screwed up.
Now that isn't all too human and in the aggregate,
completely evil outcome.
And yet he,
he doesn't have to be a psychopath to be worried about covering his ass and that
circumstance to natural human ins.
And that's if you had a system in which he would be massively rewarded in some
way for showing,
exposing that problem.
Um,
I mean it's hard to see how you would design that,
but that would be a much better system.
You know,
if the incentives were aligned in a way that,
that,
that his guilty conscience would,
would win as opposed to his,
you know,
his effort to preserve his career so he could stay free so he could stay free.
So you wouldn't get jailed or sue.
Yeah.
Or,
or just just,
no,
no longer have a career in medicine,
you know,
I mean that's,
but there are uncountable numbers of situations like that where massive
suffering a cruise.
And it's not because it was an evil person,
uh,
intend to,
yeah.
And
upon causing that suffering,
I agree 100%.
I think there's an either or.
I think you gotta be able to look at both sides.
There's an either or,
but there's a lot of evil fuckers out there.
They're doing some creepy shit.
No doubt.
Well,
at least one,
at least 1% of us are,
are,
uh,
psychopaths.
So three hours just flew by.
Wow.
That was three hours status.
That was fun.
That's a faster hours.
Yeah,
it was really enjoyable.
So your book is lying.
Uh,
you could get it at Sam Harris Org,
uh,
isn't on,
um,
like the Amazon and the stars just hitting bookstores.
Do you have an audio book?
Yeah.
Audible.
Audible,
yeah.
Oh,
beautiful.
Audibles one of our sponsors.
So perfect.
Go to audible.com forward slash Joe and get it for free.
Did they pay still?
If the book gets it,
they must have to.
Even if it's for free.
It's not for free to you think.
I think it's for,
I think it's free if you join audible.
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Beautiful.
Thanks man.
Appreciate it.
Sam Harris.
Org on Twitter.
Um,
uh,
follow him and read some books and uh,
thank you very much.
Very enjoyable.
I always a pleasure.
All right.
Thanks
everybody for tuning into the podcast.
Thanks to legal zoom.com.
Use the,
enter the code Rogan in the referral box and save yourself some money.
Thanks also to who Lou plus.
Go to Hulu plus Ford Slash Rogen and get a special offer where you can try Hulu
plus free for two weeks.
Check it out and thanks also to [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N n I t use a code name,
Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
We will be back next week.
We got a lot of podcast coming up.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we got a next week.
What do we got here?
We got Dave Asprey,
we got Maynard from tool,
we got Dan Carlin on Friday.
We've got a lot of things happen in folks,
a lot of good stuff.
Sam Harris.
Thank you brother.
I appreciate it very much.